the most interesting and
accurate studies have actually recently
come out of germany there's a there's a
big one called the vici study where they
enroll children from the year sort of
2016 to 2018 and there's been a couple
of really good papers as a result of
this big study the first study i'll
mention is um for children sort of age
one to three which is that sort of
typical toddler age
and what they did was they had 127
children that that were vegan in germany
and they analyzed their micronutrient
intakes and they wanted to see were
there any gaps how was it how was it for
the children and what was interesting is
that there were absolutely no
differences in the height no differences
in the weight
between the vegan children and the
omnivorous children in this particular
study group
both sets of children had plenty of
protein i know that's always a big
question for a lot of people is where do
they get their protein well you can get
it from plenty of places and they both
had plenty of protein the vegan children
had more fiber which is a really
important thing for reducing
constipation which is a really big
problem for a lot of kids and
interestingly they actually had more
micronutrients as well
on balance so they had more vitamin e
more vitamin b1 more folate
more vitamin c more magnesium we have a
huge body of evidence now to say that
saturated fats have been linked to
long-term health risks long-term disease
risks such as heart disease and in fact
when you look at some of the data even
children and teenagers now have fatty
streaks on their vessels in their heart
their coronary arteries
and we know this from autopsy results
there were some case studies from the
war where you had teenagers who were
fighting
in vietnam for example they did the
autopsies and they showed that these
these young people have evidence of
heart disease already forming in their
vessels these fatty streaks which then
lead to atherosclerosis
and hardening of the arteries and
hypertension
that was dr gemma newman a general
practitioner who has been practicing for
over 18 years in the uk she's a senior
partner at a family medical practice and
has a wealth of knowledge and experience
on optimizing you and your family's
health she has ob gyn family planning
and pediatric credentials as well as her
own experience transitioning her family
to plant-based many years ago
her book which has just hit stores in
the u.s the plant power doctor a simple
prescription for a healthier you is a
complete how-to go-to that is the
necessary science for people to feel
confident and empowered to thrive on
their plant-based diet
it's the perfect combination of recipe
book and information to help you as you
navigate your journey towards optimal
health and preventing disease i highly
recommend this book as i've just begun
to read it and i'm already so excited
about it and loving it dr gemma is
exactly what we need right now in this
world with so many conflicting and
confusing messaging and opinions on how
we can best thrive in this modern world
it was such a pleasure talking with her
on all things child nourishment and
raising healthy plant-based kids
something i'm also very passionate about
her approach is very inclusive towards
all types of lifestyles and how to adapt
a healthy plant-based diet and she
provides a compassionate and
understanding lens through her years of
experiencing all different types of
patients and circumstances we covered so
much in this two-hour episode from what
the science says on the benefits of
raising children plant-based and how it
stacks up against dietary patterns rich
in animal foods how to best adopt a diet
rich in whole plant foods nutrients of
focus and supplementation child teeth
health picky eater tips her thoughts on
ancestral diets breastfeeding starting
baby on solid foods and so much more dr
gemma is a breath of fresh air she's
incredibly smart and endearing and i've
had such a great conversation with her i
hope you find this conversation valuable
and enriching for you and your family's
life let's get started welcome back to
the podcast everyone i am so excited to
have you here dr gemma
and talk about all things child
nourishment and raising healthy
plant-based kids i get so many questions
about this and it's such a topic that i
think is really important and helpful to
talk about and you're so knowledgeable
about this so thank you for being here
thank you ellen i'm really delighted to
be here and honored to share time with
you and yeah it's a really important
topic and i'm really happy to be
shedding some light on it and reassuring
parents as well that's wonderful so can
you kind of set the groundwork lay the
groundwork a little bit and explain
maybe your background and how you came
to advocating what you do and being
passionate what you do yeah so i'm a
family doctor i've been a doctor for
oh
nearly 18 years a long time
and i always knew that i wanted to work
with families and
follow patients over a long period of
time get to know them
and
child health has been an integral part
of that i did pediatrics as part of my
training
but really when it came to plant-based
nutrition that came a little bit later
in my journey um and it was actually
prompted initially by my husband because
he wanted to learn how to run long
distances without getting inflamed and
injured and so he started to read about
what ultra marathon runners did people
like rich roll when he wrote finding
ultra and brandon brazier i think he's
called and scott jurett one of the most
well-known ultra runners of all time
and he decided to go plant-based and for
me
it was a bit of a new territory at that
time i was thinking oh that doesn't
sound like a good idea
are you going to be able to get
everything that you need um
and also socially i thought maybe we
would be ostracized people wouldn't
invite us over for dinner so for me it
was actually like something quite new
and then he did brilliantly with his
plant-based diet i was watching learning
uh and he's ran a marathon about an hour
and ten minutes faster than his previous
attempt which is insanely
um amazing that it's just a huge
improvement that is amazing yeah um and
it got my attention but for me
not being focused i mean i have run
marathons twice before but my focus was
not on
being an athlete or training my focus
was could this help my patients
could this improve heart disease cancer
risk
diabetes risk could it even reverse
certain disorders could it improve
autoimmune issues gut health issues and
i was really excited to find that yes
there was quite a lot of evidence to say
that it could
and
once i'd implemented it in my own life
as well i felt more confident to talk
about the practicalities of it
and when i then developed the confidence
after having read about it for so long
and i talked to my patients about it
that was really where the magic happened
and i i got to see some fantastic
results for my patients
and yeah that was the beginning and
i love talking about plant-based diets
for families too because many people go
plant-based who have children and they
want to share that lifestyle with their
children so it makes sense then to be
able to share more practical tips and
advice for families as well totally that
is so cool and actually very similar to
my husband and how he got into
plant-based eating it was a little bit
evolved because i had been plant-based
first and over time
over time he was like a little bit more
interested in it seeing myself like you
know gaining my health back and
everything like that and so then he
reads book many many books and one of
them was rich rolls book and he got into
running because he didn't used to
want to run or exercise but when he
started eating plant-based he found
himself with the energy waking up and
wanting to move and he's like i could go
for a run today and so he got so into it
and also um was running marathons and
doing incredibly well so that's so funny
how similar that aspect is with our
husbands it is it's interesting and it
also speaks to how important it is to
feel supported
because not everybody will necessarily
have a partner that's fully on board and
it's about trying to understand the
dynamic between you and as a family what
works and how old your children are and
it can really be a very individual
journey i think for a lot of families
totally it is and the best is like
mutual respect and you know listening to
each other and stuff yeah in regards to
that so what does the science the
evidence say towards the benefits of
raising children plant-based well we
have a position statement from the ada
and the bda to state that a plant-based
diet is
healthful for all stages of life
the ada goes a bit further and says that
it's also useful for helping to manage
and prevent chronic diseases as i
mentioned before heart disease cancer
things like that
the british dietetic association also
talks about the importance of a
plant-rich diet for planetary health
they have their one blue dot campaign
where they also highlight how vital it
is that we all eat more plants for
environmental and planetary health as
well as the eat lancet campaign so
there's quite a few different bodies
that state that eating more plants is
good when it comes to pediatric
nutrition
i think it's important to state that
there are a couple of agencies that have
a differing opinion there's a belgian
academy and a spanish academy of
nutrition and pediatrics that state that
they think that when you have a vegan
diet they're worried about certain
aspects for children which is why i
thought it was important to sort of
touch on yeah because when you look at
the guidelines that they've put in place
you begin to realize that a lot of those
fears are based on single case studies
and when you look at the case studies
and the detail it's generally raw diets
or whether children haven't received
enough nutrition generally enough
calories
quite specific case studies which
as you may know are essentially formal
anecdotes
and that's difficult because you you
can't really place dietary guidelines on
anecdotes um you have to look at the
large body of evidence and so what i
find interesting is that when you do
look at that
and when you look at what limited
research we have on vegan children that
they can indeed thrive
and do brilliantly on a plant-based diet
and in fact it has the potential to
reduce their risk of chronic disease
which we know but also potentially
reduce their risk of
seasonal illnesses as well um allergic
illnesses such as asthma and eczema
which we can get onto so there are a
number of potential real benefits so i
suppose one of the take-homes from
this part of the conversation is to say
if you are
having a vegan diet there's no reason
not to enjoy a vegan diet for the whole
family and in fact there are some
potential benefits it's just important
to understand that variety and planning
is is helpful yeah and having a
well-planned diet no matter what you're
eating whether you're eating plant-based
or not is still important and needs to
take be taken into consideration i mean
we see people on all kinds of diets with
animal foods that are suffering all
kinds of illnesses because of like you
said not having well planning you need
to well plan any diet and there's key
nutrients of focus that are important
and like you said with those specific
stories i've definitely seen some of
those stories i remember a couple of
them
certain ones in europe where like um
parents were feeding their infant like
under three months old like applesauce
or
regular plant milk as opposed to a
formula since they weren't breastfeeding
um and they weren't breastfeeding at all
so like things like that is just like
um
not knowledgeable not doing what a
well-planned diet would needs to entail
and so those types of examples are
really an unfair balance to what the
body of evidence shows yeah i agree it
is an unfair balance and as you rightly
pointed out you know the health
protection agency says that babies under
the age of one should have breast milk
or formula you should never feed your
baby under one a different kind of milk
especially not a homemade milk
and as you mentioned you know there are
certain case studies that of concern
with perhaps fully raw diets or not
getting enough calories for the for the
child's development yeah and again
that's really rare
these are far and away really rare cases
the vast majority of parents will have
some basic understanding of the
nutritional needs of their child and
we'll also do the research hopefully to
make sure that
they're giving the child the very best
but yeah it's true for any dietary
pattern and as you've pointed out
children on the whole in western
societies now are becoming a little bit
more
unwell in terms of increased rates of
things like asthma eczema other
allergies obesity and these are things
that could potentially be improved using
a healthy whole foods plant-based diet
yeah it's interesting how like that's
something like a poor example of a
plant-based diet will be highlighted in
the media whereas a poor example of a
diet with animal foods with a child
who's suffering from type 2 diabetes
really young and
obesity and chronic illness like that's
not going to be highlighted like what is
what is that diet looking and entailing
so there's kind of an unfair balance
because
do you think that that is the reason or
what else could be the reason why there
might be some concern for parents and
like the idea of raising your kids
plant-based like what that could look
like well
it's more of an existential question i
think people generally have a negativity
bias when it comes to the word vegan
and i would say
the media on the whole would would
sometimes have a negativity bias
whatever the age and of course our
children are so important to us you know
we you know you birth a child and you
want the very best for them and so
that's a very emotive topic so nutrition
is a motive and then child health is
even more emotive because obviously we
care about our children more than pretty
much anything else and i think perhaps
it's a combination of those things that
can lead to certain fears and
misapprehensions that i think it's
important to address
absolutely yeah so what about let's say
like some specific concerns parents
might have in regards to raising
children plant-based like if they feel
like well don't children need saturated
fat from animal foods after they're
weaned off breast milk what are your
what's your take on that and how do you
respond to that
so i would say that children do need
fats but they don't need saturated fats
we have a huge body of evidence now to
say that saturated fats have been linked
to long-term health risks long-term
disease risks such as heart disease and
in fact when you look at some of the
data even children and teenagers now
have fatty streaks on their vessels in
their heart their coronary arteries
and we know this from autopsy results
sadly when children have died in perhaps
road traffic accidents or even
there were some case studies from
the war where you had teenagers who were
fighting
in vietnam for example they did the
autopsies and they showed that these
these uh young people have evidence of
heart disease already forming in their
vessels these fatty streaks which then
lead to atherosclerosis and
and hardening of the arteries and
hypertension and and
risk of heart disease so
it's absolutely not true to say that
children need saturated fat but what
they do need are sources of dietary fat
in general yeah
i think that's an important take home
for people
because children do not thrive on a
low-fat diet
it's great because if you give them
healthy fats like
avocados and
olives
nut milks nut butters um
seed butters
coconuts these are great natural sources
of fat which will help them to absorb
fat soluble vitamins a d e and k
and also just help them get enough
calories that they need for their um
yeah for their growth their little
stomachs yeah yeah because i think
that's one of the main considerations
that people
on a more whole food plant-based diet
should keep in mind because i know that
you have a very health-conscious
audience we're not talking about the
average standard american diet probably
yeah for most of the people that follow
you yeah
people are going to be wanting to enjoy
a much more vibrant
and rich diet full of plant foods so
what i would say is perhaps slightly
different in terms of children's
nutritional needs is the absolute focus
on making sure they have a healthy fat
as much as possible with each meal yes
but also
as you've mentioned they have little
stomachs uh they're probably going to be
wanting to prioritize play time over
meal time
and so it's important to make sure that
you know they have the things they need
which is why a lot of pediatric
dietitians actually recommend a mixture
of refined grains and whole grains for
children because it allows them to
fulfill their um calorie requirement
and also um slightly less in terms of
the phytate
concentration of the grains having said
that they are less nutritionally dense
they have less zinc less selenium
and whole grains in general are far
healthier for most people but in terms
of children pediatric dietitians also
suggest you could give them a mixture of
refined and whole grains
for that reason because they've got such
little stomachs you want to make sure
that they're getting their calories that
they need
but generally speaking i think having
meals based on
those starchy carbohydrates those
healthy whole grains and a source of
plant-based protein
is a simple way to make sure that
they're having a lovely balanced meal
yep
well they're getting their
macronutrients like they're getting the
a protein-based source like carbohydrate
source and a fat source yeah at their
meals for sure exactly um so you know
what that might look like on a plate you
might give them something like you know
rice and beans you might give them like
as a snack like carrot sticks and hummus
you might be giving things like couscous
and falafels so you have sort of
an obvious starchy base with a
protein-rich meal and then you can add
in maybe a nut butter or a seed butter
or some avocado or whatever else you
like to make sure that they've got all
the things that they need in a meal yeah
that's really helpful i've definitely
found that to be the case as well like
having plenty of healthy fats and
throughout their day and every meal
being very helpful for them to get full
and to be satiated throughout their day
while also just having an abundance of
the fresh fruits and vegetables and the
whole grains and the beans the legumes
yes exactly the legumes are so important
and it's lovely to see i mean i've had
the real pleasure of seeing your
children and how how amazing and energy
filled and how thriving they are so it's
lovely to see how you implement this
practically on a day-to-day basis with
your own family it's really special
thank you so much i think the biggest
portion is really just being the example
you know like a lot of parents will have
like picky eater question tips and
um just like how to navigate like a
healthy balanced approach that um just
helps kids feel good about the food that
they're eating and for it to be just i
don't know just a really good experience
for kids that's abundant and also
nourishing them and also like
educational for them so they're like
empowered to want to make choices that
are good for their bodies that it helps
them feel good so what has been like
your experience with your kids yeah i
mean you're right i think healthy
nutritious meals in childhood lay that
foundation for children to feel
empowered to make healthy foods for
themselves as they get older and also
gives them lovely memories because
food's about so much more than nutrition
as well it's about pleasure it's about
memory making so if you're doing it with
your kids i think another tip which i'm
sure you do is is to get them involved
if they're feeling a bit like they don't
want to eat the things that you're
always um necessarily giving them say
okay well you can choose this or this
and would you like to help me prepare it
um so there's lots of tips and tricks
like that which i guess we can go into
yeah i think for my children
it's been a great journey because with
my oldest son
he was really excited about
eating more plants and he also had more
of an ethical
stance which
was really interesting and i don't know
why it surprised me because i think that
children are generally more connected to
animals than perhaps adults are but it
was a lovely thing to see so we were at
a farm park and we were picking out some
eggs from the chickens and he
he loves chickens at the time they were
his favorite
animal bird
and he was asking me
okay so
what do we eat when we eat chicken what
do we eat and i said oh will we eat
their muscles he said okay
they're muscles how do we get their
muscles
and i said oh well we we have to kill
the chicken he said you have to kill the
chicken i was like yep
like that was a real kind of jaw
dropping moment for him and he said he
was only four
or three
very very young
and he said well how do we how do we
kill the chicken i don't know i don't
really know um
and i was thinking i'm really down a
difficult path here um a stun gun maybe
a knife yeah um i'm not really sure and
he said oh okay
and the look on his face and i said look
if you don't want to eat chickens you
don't have to eat chickens we've got
lots of other ways that we can have
really enjoyable foods and i listed all
the foods that he
eats that didn't have chicken in and
that he loves and he's like yeah i don't
want to eat chicken yeah i don't want to
eat chickens anymore so for him it was
really an extension of his love for the
animals which then helped him to feel a
lot more aligned to this way of living
whereas for my younger son he grew up
with it so it's just something that he
knows because that's what we do as a
family and it was in a way
an easier transition i would imagine
than for other parents who
perhaps took on a more plant-based
lifestyle when the children were
maybe sort of eight nine ten or teenage
years where you know you have a little
bit more of a sort of a fixed pattern in
the way
the children like to eat so it was a lot
easier i imagined them for some parents
because ted had just grown up with it
and that's just what we eat at home
we've talked about it so he understands
that there is an active decision in
things that we eat rather than just
taking whatever's there and and eating
whatever's available like there's a lot
of conscious thought that goes into the
foods that we provide and that's
something that we discuss as a family
but it's interesting because every
family is very unique and it's a real
learning journey because a lot of
families
you know the one parent or other may
start a plant-based journey and not
really know exactly what they're doing
and find their own way and then want to
introduce it to the family when they
feel more confident
i don't know how that was for you you
mentioned that you that you had a vegan
lifestyle from very young so you had
already decided to be vegan before you
had your first child
yeah i was 19 when i went plant-based
vegan and so my kids have all been you
know plant-based since conception
and i breastfed all of them and that's
pretty much all they've known
but they have a lot of friends who are
not plant-based so they're around
it all the time and so they're very
actively aware and in the conversations
of how
um because they also have that ethical
connection
where they think about the animals and
so just
just the educational conversations
surrounding around love and mutual
respect for everyone
and the active choices that you can make
on your own when you're at parties or
gatherings and stuff and
my eldest is like especially really
appreciative when i go out of my way to
go get a vegan version for him of
whatever the part they're going to be
serving at a party right um like if we
know there's going to be pizza and like
regular cake at a party
you know what recently actually he had a
baseball game and i was going to go
watch his baseball game but there was a
party for one of the kids after the game
and
i asked him i'm like do you want me to
go you know like stop it at the grocery
store and pick up these foods for you
during your game and he's like oh i
would so appreciate that yes that would
be awesome so i went and picked up you
know a vegan cupcake and um like a
plant-based burger with taro in it and
some like vegan sushi hand rolls like
his favorite foods that were there and
brought to the party and after the party
he was like thank you so much mom like
that food was so delicious it was so
much better than any of the food even
looked at the party and it was so good i
really appreciate it and it just like
you know
kids are really appreciative when they
get to
socialize and also like with their
friends but also be able to make the
choices that they want to make so
and also helping them to feel empowered
and loved like if they don't end up
wanting to make that choice you know
because that way they know that like mom
and dad loves me no matter what i end up
choosing yeah exactly i think and every
family's going to navigate those things
in their own way yeah um i'm looking
back on all the parties that we were
invited to for the from my boys and you
know quite often you're right people
won't necessarily have all vegan options
there and we would say to our oldest son
you know you can have what you want to
eat at the party
but if you wanted to wait we could give
you a nice piece of cake or some ice
cream
at home if you want to try that at home
instead and sometimes he would just say
actually yeah i want to wait and in fact
every time now i look back on it i don't
think he ever actually ended up choosing
yeah but because he had the choice yeah
he liked i think he liked the fact that
he had the choice yeah i think i think
what's so important in raising kids is
like you know surrounding with like love
and respect and like education an
example like really i get a lot of
questions about picky eaters so did you
have any um experience with
transitioning maybe your eldest or do
you have advice for parents who do have
questions like that when you who come
into your practice who are wanting to
eat more plant-based raise their kids
that way like what picky eater advice do
you have yeah i think it's
it's interesting because different
families have different ways of doing
things but what i found to be really
helpful
is the idea that you know essentially
the parent tends to choose
generally what's put on the plate and
then the child should really get to
choose how much of it they eat
and
some families have like a one bite rule
or a one spoon rule when it comes to new
foods just to kind of give a little
taste of something new but we also have
to remember that research tells us that
it's really common for young babies and
children and especially toddler years
it may take 10 to 15 attempts at a new
food for for a young child to think yeah
i want to have that again
and so don't get disheartened if you've
given something 10 11 times and every
time the child rejects it just think
okay well it'll be on the plate just a
taster every single time and then
eventually they usually do have a little
bit um or decide that actually they like
it now or you know so
it's not something where you try it once
and if they reject it that's it you can
leave a little bit on the plate every
single time and see what happens
um and
i think also portion sizes are sometimes
confusing for parents because
we often would give a portion that we
think that they should eat but then
actually their stomachs are just too
small to really want to have that much
food
so when you think about things like
whole grains if you look at the size of
your child's fist closed fist that's
about the portion of a whole grain that
you'd give your child and if you look at
their hands spread out open and you look
at the size of their palm not the
fingers if you have two palms full
that's about the right sort of portion
for fruit or vegetables and you can see
if you just look at your child's palm
actually hmm that might be a bit smaller
than i've been aiming for yeah
so don't get disheartened if you put a
really big plate of food and they just
want to pick at it or they're nibbling
or they're not eating it so that's
another tip is to sort of relax
sometimes when you bring a lot of
anxiety i think to the dinner table it
can cause a battle of wills
and when it becomes a battle of wills
you never win because you either let
your child win or you win at the expense
of your relationship with your child
absolutely so
try to relax
try to make it fun
involve them if you can
they have choices maybe one or two not
more than that
and
you know obviously things that you have
decided that you're willing to make that
day
and then they choose how much of it they
want to eat and
if you have a neurotypical child they
generally won't let themselves go hungry
but
i would say it's a special case if your
child has autism or certain sensory
processing issues um you may need to get
the specialist help of a perhaps a
dietitian or a nutritionist if they have
developed very sort of rigid ideas about
the foods and the taste and the textures
that they're willing to eat
yeah that's all such good advice um i've
definitely found the best the best uh
experience that i've had with my kids
it's just being the example and what you
said about the you know what we have at
the table this is what we're eating we
do that at dinner time and it's like
whatever we make this is what we're
eating we don't make special separate
foods for the kids we don't make
something for us and then something for
them it's like this is what we eat
together as a family and they know that
going into it this is family dinner we
don't make something else in regards to
like breakfast and lunch and snacks i
love to have like an empowered decision
for them whether like what do you want
to eat do you want to help me make it
a lot of times they like to be able to
make it on their own it really helps
them feel empowered and loved by their
parents i think to just know that we
trust them and are there if they need
help and then just like getting them in
the garden even if you have just a
little garden for a certain time of year
if you live in somewhere with like a
strong climate like when they get to
pick their own
anything
they generally get really excited to eat
it if they pick their kale from the
garden or tomatoes from the garden or
whatever it is i feel like that just
helps kids feel so excited we were
picking carrots from our garden they
were just like what can we do with this
let's juice it into some vegetables or
let's let's eat it in a salad and they
just get so excited to see the whole
process unfold
and then
with things like vegetables i think a
lot of times
um
when kids really don't like vegetables
tell me what you think about this i
think a lot of times it's like a taste
bud related thing if they've grown up
eating a lot of hyper processed highly
processed foods with a lot of flavor of
salt sugar oil in everything that
they're eating that a simple plain fruit
or vegetable is generally not nearly
near as appealing and so it's just one
of those things like you said just you
know having patience and then being the
example too because for me i'm like if
i'm making a salad i'm like does it do
any of you guys want to make a salad
with me elvis is always a yes because he
loves salads sandy is a sometimes scout
is a sometimes so if they're like nah
i'm like all right so i just make it for
me and elvis and then they always end up
on my shoulder and they're eating the
salad with me because they see me eating
this out they're like oh that actually
does look good and they see me enjoying
it and loving it and also when i explain
the nutritional benefits that i feel
from enjoying these like tender greens
and they get excited and they actually
get really excited when they know these
foods are helping my body you know in
this way or that with my strength and my
um my hair and all these different
things i kind of like like to educate on
that and that excites them too yeah
that's a really lovely way of doing it
because you want to focus on the things
that will make them feel vibrant and
strong and healthy and also as you say
to involve them with it and they when
they see it they want to have it and
also maybe make it a fun thing like you
know i remember a phase where i would
turn an avocado into a car from my for
my oldest child and i'd sort of turn it
upside down and i i would make cucumber
wheels for the car and then i would sort
of slice it so it looked like a car yes
and he was so excited by that that was
like a snack or something he loved it
and celery sticks i put like an almond
butter and a celery stick and then i put
little raisins in and it was ants on a
boat yeah and he loved it and he wanted
to eat the whole thing and you know yeah
it just it's quite fun to get creative
but at the same time
like you say with a family meal you
don't want to be making like five
different meals you've got your fifth
baby on the way you imagine having to do
seven meals or six meals that's crazy so
having having one big family meal is
lovely and then the kids hopefully can
get excited about what they have yeah
for sure for sure oh there's so much to
say about even just this topic of like
helping kids love the food that they're
eating the nourishing foods that's good
for them um we've totally had our days
too where we make like funny faces out
of
apples and bananas and different fruits
and they love that i think it's really
helpful too not to add more onto our
plate as mothers that we already have
our parents fathers too um but like
making your food beautiful yeah um is is
something that's enticing not only for
us but for the kid for kids too it's
true
i think basically a real fail-safe from
my point of view which doesn't require
any more effort is just to make a smiley
face
pretty much a smiley face when anything
works yeah you could do it with oatmeal
um you could do it with anything on the
plate different veggies
and it just yeah it makes them want to
eat it a little bit more perfect
okay so i want to get a little bit back
into like the science of this because i
do um think that that is really helpful
for parents who are kind of like well
how do my kids need animal foods at all
do they need some should like what is
the most optimal for well-being and so
some people do kind of align or look at
like maybe studies that are presented
that animal foods are
you know um
providing or supporting these types of
negative health outcomes like heart
disease and stuff and think well these
studies don't
include
testing on like grass-fed beef or
um
you know raw milk and something
something like that so what are your
thoughts on that because if you look at
a lot of studies they're just like they
might be testing it's like standard
diets against a plant-based diet from a
holistic family who is being conscious
about their food so what are your
thoughts on that
so
i get that people would feel that way
because people are wanting to eat a more
natural way maybe the way that their
ancestors ate
but then when you look at what we have
in terms of data i think
ancestral ways of eating can be very
varied across the globe
and you know what your ancestors say
might be quite different from what when
one of your neighbors ancestors ate
but also how far back are we talking
when it comes to ancestors if we if we
go back millions of years then the vast
majority of those ancestors would
literally have just had stuff like
vegetables or fruits
you know they would have picked up maybe
on a few insects here and there fungus
on leaves like i don't really fancy
eating that
ancestrally so
i think it's important to try and
understand well what do we mean by an
ancestral way of eating um and what
specific benefits are you really looking
for
it's true to say that
clearly
meat has played a role in many different
kinds of diets over the generations
but the i'd say the majority of foods
that humans have thrived on over the
generations has been
plant-based fruits veggies whole grains
legumes and we have genetic adaptations
to enjoy cooked
foods to enjoy legumes to enjoy grains
we have extra amylase enzymes that we
have in our mouth so that we we know
that we are um designed in a way to be
able to enjoy these abundant plant foods
so
that's if you like an ancestral way of
eating
as well it just really depends on how
far back you go and we i think people
focus on paleolithic man
a lot like paleo diets
but if you look at paleolithic stool
samples you see that they have hugely
fibrous diets like about 150 grams a day
of fiber which is
unthinkable compared to how much fiber
we eat now which i think the guidelines
say
30 grams is ideal and we tend to have ab
somewhere between 15 and 18 grams yeah
that's standard american yeah yeah so
when you look at it that way you think
okay well there's a huge amount of fiber
that we're missing out on if we were
going to eat
paleo then we would have to eat a ton
more fiber than we do even now even on a
healthy plant-based diet we'd have to
probably double or triple the amount of
fiber that we're eating which i think is
an interesting way of looking at that
right
so
i'd say what's optimal um is
what you feel you can make and what you
feel you can enjoy in in the confines of
mainly whole foods vegetables fruits
whole grains beans lentils chickpeas
herbs spices nuts and seeds
i can't say there's any data to say that
you have to be plant exclusive
you don't have to be plant exclusive but
i would say that being plant exclusive
can
have benefits and it's not something to
be afraid of
so i guess if we could word it that way
yeah i think that's a really good way to
word it because you're right when you
talk about things like grass-fed beef
and raw milk and pasture eggs and stuff
it is often associated with like
ancestral eating and you're right i
think it generally goes back to just
pre-processed foods
industry is considered ancestral and but
i the thing is though both types of
eating or people who are advocating for
different ways either plant predominant
or plant exclusive or eating like a lot
of animal based foods and just getting
it from a better source right than doing
factory farm both people are on the same
page the ultra processed foods are not
optimal for us and so it's really just
like
tackling and getting down to the
nitty-gritty of like how many plants
should we really be eating but the way
that you explain that about how
our physiology is designed to be plant
predominant and it's very clear about
that and then the way that you're
explaining the data too i think we were
talking the other day
as well about the seven-day adventists
you want to talk a little bit about that
yeah sure i mean that's an interesting
group of people because the seventh-day
adventists mainly i think based around
loma linda in california and they are a
health conscious group of people
it's part of their faith tradition to
want to look after their bodies and be
healthy but there will be a mixture of
them so some of them would be meat
eaters some of them would be vegetarian
some of them would be fully vegan and in
fact there's a significant proportion of
seventh-day adventists who are fully
plant-based and what is interesting is
when you look at those adventist studies
you see that there is definitely an
increased risk of diabetes increased
risk of being overweight
carrying excess weight the more animal
products the adventists ate so the less
that they ate the more likely they were
to have a normal bmi and have a reduced
risk of diabetes whereas the more they
even in this health conscious population
the more the risks of having an
unhealthy bmi and having diabetes yeah i
think that's a really good group to
bring up because when you're comparing
these ways of life they're all eating
holistically living holistically too
because a lot of times you know there's
other factors in regards to our health
in regards to our movement and our sleep
and just our consciousness of living
well other than just our food but all
these people are doing that and having
varied
amounts of animal foods down to none and
to see the difference is really helpful
and also just looking at basic
population studies like in country
there's a country uh i think it was in
finland they had horrendous rates of
heart disease
before the second world war um one of
the the largest in the world and they
had a big public health campaign and
during the second world war meat was
really restricted there was rationing
and after the second world war when they
did the big public health campaign
they were essentially telling the people
to eat much less meat and eat loads more
veggies
obviously to cut smoking and things like
that and what they found was that these
simple
measures helped the people of that
country to have vastly reduced rates of
heart disease compared to before now you
would you would think if you're talking
about just being unprocessed and just
not having factory farmed meats that
that wouldn't make much of a difference
but it made a huge difference to this
vast population of people heart disease
rates dropped dramatically after they
were advised and
told to eat more vegetables right i
think that's a really good point and now
a word from our sponsors
did you know that you swallow five to
seven percent of your toothpaste every
single time you brush your teeth that's
an entire blob of toothpaste every seven
days most commercial toothpastes are
filled with harsh chemicals artificial
flavors and preservatives not stuff you
want to be putting in your mouth let
alone eating that's why bite makes
toothpaste tablets made with clean
ingredients that are sulfate palm oil
and glycerin free and my holistic
dentist fully approves there's a
specific ingredient she highly
recommends for brushing teeth called
hydroxyapatite and it's in these awesome
toothpaste bits and on top of that the
jars are so pretty it comes in
refillable glass jars and they send
refills and compostable pouches so
they're better for our bodies and our
earth no more plastic toothpaste tubes
bite toothpaste bits are so convenient
you just pop a bit in your mouth chew it
up and start brushing it will turn into
paste just like you're used to but with
no plastic tube or messy paste which
makes it extra convenient for kids who
think popping a bite in their mouth is
so fun and makes tooth brushing time a
pleasant experience it honestly felt a
little weird at first but now my whole
family is obsessed it's so effective and
makes my teeth extremely clean i ran out
of bite toothpaste once so i went back
to my old regular toothpaste and very
quickly i realized that my teeth didn't
feel as clean so i'm never going back to
pace and we'll be using bite from here
on out bite makes plastic free
alternatives for everything on your
bathroom sink so you can cut out the
harsh chemicals and plastic waste
without compromise and bite is offering
my listeners 20 off your first order go
to
trybite.com
ellen or use the code ellen at checkout
to claim this deal that's t-r-y-b-i-t-e
dot com
ellen we're also brought to you today by
buffy you guys i'm telling you every
time a friend or guest lays down in
these sheets and comforter they are
blown away by how soft and cozy it is
and i can say without a doubt that buffy
enhances my sleep so in addition to that
what's so great about buffy is that they
are dedicated to making a positive
impact on not only our sleep but also
the environment using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed
their debut product the cloud comforter
is covered in super soft eucalyptus
fabric and filled with fluffy fiber made
from 100 recycled bottles this comforter
has over 18 thousand five star reviews
it keeps you at the perfect temperature
so you feel cozy without overheating and
it is by far my favorite comforter i've
ever slept with it's hypoallergenic and
machine washable thanks to an innovative
stitching batter that keeps its fluffy
fill in place plus its high thread count
shuts out dust mold and mites for a
healthier sleep environment the best
part for me though is that the average
down comforter harms 12 geese but
buffy's comforter is made cruelty free
it feels even softer than down while
keeping approximately 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans so use my code
ellen for twenty dollars off orders over
eighty dollars you can try comforter in
your own bed for free if you don't love
it return it at no cost maybe maybe they
wanna respond to be like well what about
another country who eats a lot of animal
foods and they don't have high heart
disease risks like how would you respond
to that
so i think the most common one that
people bring up is
the populations of alaska where you have
primarily fish
and
what i find interesting about that is
when you look at heart disease rates
they are actually pretty high
and those populations have had to learn
to survive in the extremes
of human capacity and i think that also
draws back on what we were discussing
earlier which is it's not so much the
diet that we should thrive on but i
think humans are designed to survive in
a variety of different settings
and so you know when it comes to looking
at the blood vessels of people from you
know these traditionally alaskan
populations or inuit populations
they have you know thickening of their
arteries they have a high you know
calcium schools things like that
potentially because you know they're
having all fish and or meat products but
i wouldn't tell them not to do that
because that is their history that is
what was available um so i think
generally speaking
we should have a lot less judgment when
it comes to the foods that we choose to
eat but also to remember
a lot of the time you know humans
throughout history have been surviving
you know there have been huge amounts of
nutritional deficiencies in our
ancestors
um
in the uk for example looking at thyroid
function and iodine levels
there was a condition called lancashire
neck which happened when
um people in from parts of the world
called lancashire which is in the uk
didn't have enough iodine because there
was not enough iodine in the soil and
they're having a lot of potatoes and
things that were grown in iodine
depleted soils and so they developed
goiter which is where the the thyroid
gland swells up and it causes issues
with the thyroid function and it was
actually called lancashire neck because
in that part of the world there was less
iodine within the soil
is that optimal is that unsafe not
really is it ancestral well maybe
because that's what you know that's
really the answer how long ago was that
was that like pre-processed food
industry of course yeah so this is the
thing i think a lot of times people i
love all these examples you're bringing
up a lot of times people want to blame
one thing like oh it's it's a seed oils
or it's sugar or it's oil or whatever
right like
and i get that and those it may be those
things part of it but there's it's not
just like one thing there's a lot of
different factors that create good
health and that's such a good point to
say that just because our ancestors ate
a certain way doesn't mean that they
were actually thriving because living to
survive is what our species had to do is
they traveled across different lands and
i think this is the perfect example
with that for dairy that people kind of
when people try to say that dairy is
part of our physiology well we know that
it's not because it's designed for a
baby calf to grow into a great big cow
but on top of that layer if you're
talking about ancestrally like having
cows and dairy was a
significant food source when you're
traveling to a different land where you
don't know what the food source is going
to be like and to be able to have that
something that's filling and does have
nutrients in it it makes sense why that
happened throughout our history and our
ancestry it completely makes sense yeah
it doesn't mean that's how we were
designed to thrive it completely makes
sense that we would have had dairy
because as you say in certain parts of
europe
in the winter months people were not
going to be able to have access to those
nutritional delicious foods and so they
would have relied on dairy as a great
stop gap and it would have contained
lots of different nutrients that they
would have needed to survive but that
doesn't mean that they would necessarily
have thrived that way so we're so
fortunate that in this time
in human history we have access to a lot
of different healthy foods most of us
and i think in a way the debates around
ancestral diets or paleo diets or vegan
diets or keto diets is is actually quite
is difficult for me because what i see
day to day is people struggling people
on the bread line people who need to use
food banks
and i find these questions
sometimes difficult because i think most
people are literally just trying to
think one day to the next how am i going
to feed my family
and from my perspective if they have the
mental bandwidth to
bulk buy grains or legumes or learn to
cook them then that is going to be
probably the cheapest way for them to be
able to provide optimal nutrition for
their families and i think that's the
discussion that many of us should be
having rather than oh well what if so
what about yes i think that's such a
good point it's so true and what that's
something that is actually quite
beautiful about the plant-based diet or
plant-predominant diet that you know it
is quite affordable when you're eating
whole foods based like the beans and
rice as a staple because they are very
low in calories especially when you're
cooking from scratch
um like the dried beans it's so so cheap
it's very cheap but yeah is that well is
the staple food for many populations
around the globe for a reason yeah you
know there's and there's a lot of good
nutrients in there soaking and sprouting
helps because it helps to
reduce those completely natural
compounds in plants oxalates um
phytates which as i say completely
natural in all plants nothing wrong with
them but sometimes they can and slightly
inhibit some of the absorption of other
minerals like iron so soaking and
sprouting of grains and and beans has
been really common ancestrally again
so is that ancestral diet well yes it is
many people have had to do that over the
years to make sure they optimize the
amount of nutrition they get from these
amazing foods i think that's all those
are all such great points and i love
just how well that you and other
plant-based doctors talk about the wide
body of evidence of eating predominantly
plant-based or whole foods plant-based
to help set our
ourselves up to help prevent and lower
our risk of heart disease and cancers
and certain things like that so what you
said about beans and rice it makes me
think of subsidies and how animal foods
should be significantly more expensive
if we didn't have the subsidies that are
in place at least in america today
well they should be i suppose if you if
you take all the costs into account
including environmental costs including
the cost of of what it would take to
ethically raise an animal um and you
know what that involves so yeah it would
be a lot more expensive if it was the
real cost right um but you're asking me
about data and i think
what's interesting is you know when you
look at children
there's not many studies that would
actively put a diet in place for a child
but you can look at people who in
different populations have used
different forms of nutrition and analyze
it that way i think probably the best um
or at least i say best the most
interesting and
accurate studies have actually recently
come out of germany there's a there's a
big one called the vichy study where
they enrolled children from the year
sort of 2016 to 2018 and there's been a
couple of really good papers as a result
of this big study which i hope will
reassure parents that are vegan that it
would be a really lovely idea to raise
your children vegan too and not to feel
scared about it because like the first
study i'll mention is um for children
sort of age one to three which is that
sort of typical toddler age
and what they did was they had 127
children that that were vegan in germany
and they analyzed their micronutrient
intakes and they wanted to see when were
there any gaps how was it how was it for
the children and what was interesting is
that there were absolutely no
differences in the height no differences
in the weight
between the vegan children and the
omnivorous children in this particular
study group
both sets of children had plenty of
protein i know that's always a big
question for a lot of people is where
they get their protein well you can get
it from plenty of places and they both
had plenty of protein the vegan children
had more fiber which is a really
important thing for reducing
constipation which is a really big
problem for a lot of kids it's a lot of
what i see in clinic actually is
children suffering from severe
constipation which is an awful
situation to be in for children so yeah
they had more fiber and interestingly
they actually had more micronutrients as
well um on balance so they had more
vitamin e more vitamin b1 more folate
more vitamin c more magnesium
so yeah i think
yeah it's it's it's an interesting study
now when you look at the um if there was
any kind of patterns to it the
omnivorous children generally had a
little bit more in the way of things
like zinc
and dha
and iodine but the vegan children were
not deficient
in any of those things on average
and there's plenty of ways to get those
things so
if you know where the key nutrients are
you can find yourself in a position
where your child actually has more of
most micronutrients compared to the
standard way of eating that's so great i
think that there's a couple things i
want to say in response i think this
type of information is really helpful
because like you said sometimes parents
are concerned about raising their kids
plant-based and i think the majority of
it is from kind of the fear propaganda
campaign that it happens just in regards
to our media and
even just well-meaning parents and what
we have been taught growing up like i
was definitely taught that i needed
these foods to be healthy like animal
foods when i was young
and by kind of unlearning what were
taught as a generational just
understanding to looking at the evidence
i think that's that's really really
helpful for parents and the other aspect
is the specific nutrients that you're
talking about i know a lot of people
want to know and have questions about
specific nutrients so should we get into
that i'm just getting into it i'm so
excited to talk about this and also i
want to touch on breastfeeding which
we'll get there let's get into it yeah
like we're going to talk at the
beginning but i'm like we have so many
things to talk about
i know there's so many things we can
discuss but we can get into it so one of
the things i forgot to say actually is
what i found from the study reading it
was that the vegan children they also
had much higher vitamin b12 levels oh
that wasn't that interesting interesting
that is very interesting let's put the
i'll put the link to that study below
for people to check out you can get that
one for me that sounds like a really
interesting study it is um
so the reason why the vegan children had
higher vitamin b12 is because their
parents supplement it yeah and i do
think it's important to say if you're
fully plant-based that a b12 supplement
is something that's important for um a
visual lifestyle
um but looking at the other nutrients i
guess um you know we could start with
things like iron
that's a common one of focus
and
maybe try and remember blt
not bacon lettuce tomato but um beans
lentils and tofu those are great sources
of plant-based iron and protein
and it's nice to remember okay if you're
at the supermarket thing okay blt i'm
gonna make sure i go down get myself
some beans get myself some
lentils maybe get some like calcium um
uh tofu so you've got extra calcium
there as well um and it's just a nice
aid memoir for parents but there's loads
of sources of iron um
and interestingly if you have vitamin c
with your iron it can increase the
absorption between two and four times so
when you're thinking about feeding your
children you think okay well if i have a
lentil bolognese i'll have some broccoli
on the side because i've got the vitamin
c which will help absorb the iron from
the lentils or something also like
citrus like lemon or lime on a salad
like a green salad or orange juice fresh
orange juice in a smoothie with collard
greens exactly it really helps the
absorption or if you have oatmeal make
sure that you maybe put something like
strawberries or kiwi on top to help
increase the vitamin c concentration
with your iron rich foods which makes
your food beautiful anyways and all this
stuff all the stuff that you're talking
about makes your food more beautiful and
appealing as well exactly exactly but
it's just a nice thing to think okay
where's my vitamin c where's my iron and
make sure you can get it and essentially
these minerals are abundant in a lot of
plant-based foods but it's just i think
variety is is great so if you have a
nice variety then you know okay i'm
gonna get everything i need and that
includes things like selenium um as well
and zinc uh again for zinc you could
think um beans again lentils again um
oats are a great source of zinc pumpkin
seeds right pumpkin seeds chickpeas
so yeah i think maybe remember for iron
you've got your blt maybe zinc you've
got block bloc so you've got beans
lentils oats chickpeas pumpkin seeds as
you mentioned so i mean there's but
there's a ton like if you go online you
could literally see a massive list of
vegan sources of these things but
sometimes it's nice to have that little
egg memoir yeah you know okay great and
make sure i'm having that and also just
a lot of the stuff just revolves around
whole plant foods it's really easy in
our modern day world to get into a rut
of just buying more processed foods even
if it is maybe less ultra processed but
it is still processed foods because it
says vegan on it and it's plant-based
but the more whole foods that all these
foods you're mentioning that we can get
into our family's home and into our diet
is just going to help ensure all those
nutrient profiles and i think it's
important to say too as we're talking
about specific nutrients that every diet
whether rich in animal foods or rich in
plants
has nutrients of focus to focus on so
while we're talking about plant
predominant or plant-based kids let's
keep going with these specific nutrients
and it's important it's good that you
said that ellen because the fact that
we're talking about key nutrients of
focus i don't want people to think oh
that means that this is something that
you know other people don't have to
think about there are other nutrients of
focus on a meat-heavy diet for sure
magnesium and folate potassium all the
things i mentioned from the viti study
will be potentially lower if you're not
really thinking about what you're giving
your total children so and all these um
these diets that are advocating for more
like um ancestral way western a price or
paleo or anything like that they most of
them are still taking some form of
supplement as well so sometimes people
will say oh if you need a b12 supplement
then that means that you shouldn't be
totally plant-based but i mean they're
even injecting b12 into farm animals
these days yeah that's a really
important point you know we are all
supplementing or fortifying in ways that
we don't realize
in fact i don't know if it's the same in
the us but in the uk
our bread is fortified with b vitamins
thymine things like that
our
we're fortunate enough to have many
plant milks that are fortified as well
which i think is actually a really great
option if you're raising plant-based
kids is to look at the label and double
check is my plant milk fortified because
that's a lovely way of making sure i
don't have to think as hard and i know
that they're getting vitamin d getting
iodine you know getting calcium because
cow milks are also fortified and the
iodine doesn't come naturally in cow's
milk it's used in the cleansing of the
vats that they use to collect the milk
and so why is that more natural than
having a plant milk with iodine
supplements that's interesting i think
we live in a modern world that just like
sometimes requires that type of
fortification it doesn't mean it always
needs to be the case like i think that's
a great example for people who want to
not think about it as hard or don't
maybe live in a place where they can
garden and get you know food from the
farmer's market as often as someone like
ourselves who has the opportunity to get
most of our plants from like really
nutrient rich soil but if you don't have
that opportunity and you live in a
faster paced world like it does make
sense to be able to that adding
something like that do you want to talk
about that study you were talking about
with the fortified milk oh yeah well i
was talking about a pediatric nutrition
a pediatric dietitian who um did a
presentation which i watched and it was
fascinating because she laid out some
really simple foods that a vegan toddler
would have uh
like you know things like carrot sticks
and hummus and oatmeal and like you know
maybe a bean dish
um and
what she found is that when you give the
toddler the same meal but instead you
use fortified products like fortified
milk basically to make the oatmeal or a
small glass of fortified milk as part of
their daily routine then it immediately
plugged any issues with regard to things
like iodine
or b12 or selenium intake so it's just a
really lovely way of knowing
if you are not able to
you know focus so hard on making sure
that you're going and getting all of
these sort of natural organic products
yeah okay my child's going to have this
and that from their plant milk and it's
just it's an easy win yeah i think it's
really helpful to provide different
perspectives of different ways of
approaching a plant-based diet because
like the way that you're describing not
everybody has the same kind of lifestyle
as someone like myself where i like
really love and appreciate to be eating
as much whole foods as we can and not
really so much fortified stuff so for me
i make my own plant milk but we also my
kids eat dulce every week all throughout
the week which is rich in iodine and or
i see let only say iodine but like
because i heard you say iodine
you're both saying iodine yeah yeah
i love it but it's so british yeah but
there's like
i i tend to do that when i'm around like
a friend for a long time i start to
adapt to their mannerisms or the way
that they talk um but yeah so certain
there's nutrients of focus that like i
really love to get from whole foods
sources instead of doing which is great
yeah which is great because i love it i
just love to make things from scratch
and i love for my kids to be part of the
process and so we do a lot of sea veggie
dulce um so my kid i feel confident that
my kids are getting their iodine covered
as like a specific example but for
someone who's like my kid doesn't like
dolls or i don't have time to make
salads every day for my kids that is a
really great alternative for whatever
you're saying it is yeah and it's also
important to know you know when it comes
to iodine
many people are iodine deficient
globally it's one of the iron is one of
the biggest deficiencies globally iodine
is also really very significant and
again this is not vegan populations this
is generally a lot of people are iodine
deficient so
it's just important to be aware of
iodine sources and nori sheets are great
because you can use those to make sushi
rolls you can use them
just as a snack
and they have a pretty decent amount of
iodine in them
but
i would say be cautious when it comes to
all different kinds of sea plants like
um
kelp for example can sometimes have a
lot of iodine and it's a bit like
goldilocks you know you don't want to
have too much of it exactly as well as
not having yeah too little right so if
you're unsure and your kids don't enjoy
nori sheets or adults those flakes or
whatever else
it's okay to just include it in a nut
milk or in a supplement a
non-seaweed-based supplement is okay
yeah and they often come in multi-bit
anyway for kids so and this goes for
anyone who's listening who aren't even
maybe raising their kids plant-based but
they just wanted more
just nutrition in their family's diet
and so like you were saying like with
the iodine just being something a key
nutrient focus for anyone on any side
exactly yeah and so for us like with
something like selenium we include like
a brazil nut here there every once in a
while throughout our like homemade
granolas that we make i just like to
make a lot of foods from scratch but
again just prefacing for those who don't
have the time for that and want to cover
their needs i love the way that you're
approaching that yeah and taking in
consideration from that because you
probably see all kinds of people in your
practice i see all kinds and many people
that really don't have the mental
bandwidth and luckily you know you you
have such an incredible lifestyle and
your followers will obviously be
emulating a lot of the things you do and
i would agree totally that whole foods
um and more conscious thought behind
what you're eating is is just incredible
and is the way to go but um you know
everybody's quite different when it
comes to their family lives and stuff
like that and different work lives too
like and there's no shame in that
there's literally no
need to try to compare i think
comparison is a thief of joy and that's
why
i think that's one of the my favorite
statements unless you're inspired yeah
right you've got to have a good feeling
that comes from
like wow that is so great yeah i'd love
to do that i'm going to start doing it
with that
i guess i look at it more as like i'm
looking at someone and what am i
inspired by them as opposed to comparing
themselves to myself yeah you know yeah
but yeah the different lifestyles really
are important to preface for people
let's talk about k2 yeah so
we we talked about selenium and brazil
nuts hopefully people will pick up on
that yeah brazil nuts are great and one
a day for adults is is great um
but you can also get selenium from other
things like oats and it's interesting so
how so many of the plant-based foods
essentially if you're just combining um
various whole grains and legumes you're
going to have a lot of the different
minerals too right including selenium
and that's why i love what um dr wilbul
sweats talks about the wide variety of
plant-based diversity because if you're
like getting a diverse if you're just
eating the same kind of beans the same
kind of oats and the same couple fruits
throughout your week every single week
like you're less likely to cover all
those bases if you're just getting a
variety of different kinds of beans
different kinds of grains yeah
definitely so that's that's one take
home for everyone is variety is great
great for the gut and great for your
micronutrient intake um so you talked
about you mentioned k2 so yeah k vitamin
is important it helps with
blood
clotting it also helps with calcium
metabolism
now interestingly children
in many parts of the world are vitamin k
deficient whatever they eat that's
interesting so in the uk
we are advised uh to let parents know
that um vitamin k supplementation under
the age of five is is preferable there's
actually a vitamin um
or vitamin uh it's called aberdek and it
contains um vitamin a vitamin k and
vitamin d
and it's advised for all children under
five so again it's actually we know when
you're looking at large populations of
people whatever they're eating there is
there are certain gaps there yeah that
may be good to fill so when it comes to
vitamin k1 you can get that from leafy
greens
when it comes to k2 you can get it
either from animal products or fermented
foods
so if you are having a fermented food
rich diet things like
miso is great
for providing k2
natto is but i have to say i've never
tried it and people say it doesn't taste
great not good
but i would say focusing on fermented
foods if you wanted to get a natural
source of vitamin k2 is a good idea but
also there's so much more to it i think
good gut health again maybe going back
to your episode with dr b good gut
health is so great because it helps your
gut bugs to manufacture certain items
that that you would otherwise be missing
and so are we more vitamin k deficient
because we live in a world where we use
a lot of antibiotics where we use a lot
of pesticides where our gut microbes are
perhaps
not going to be as efficient at helping
us to make these things so k there's
actually about 12 different subtypes of
vitamin k and many of them can be
manufactured with a healthy gut
microbiome
but how are we going to know i think
that is such a good point because often
times it feels a little bit tedious and
odd to be focusing so hyper on like
specific nutrients sometimes like yeah
where am i gonna get this exact nutrient
what about this nutrient am i am i gonna
like experience all these issues if i
don't have this exact one but i think
the whole the holistic approach of our
lifestyles
really plays a role like you're talking
about with our gut health and stress can
affect your gut optimization as well so
looking at your lifestyle with your
children as well like since this episode
is about children like are they getting
restful sleep are we making sure their
sleep is a priority where they hopefully
get to sleep in get to bed early enough
going to bed with full tummy so they
sleep really well
you know all of those types of things
helping to lower the stress in your own
life so that you can be a more calm
parent so that they're less stressed out
and high strung you want them to feel
balanced and they're going to just do a
lot better that way so true ellen it's
so true there are so many different
factors that essentially involve a
healthy happy life that would also help
us
to to include those different nutrients
without getting so specific yeah um but
yeah our gut bugs they pretty much they
help us to absorb the right amount of
protein from our food they help us to
make thiamine and vitamin k and vitamin
b12 and a lot of other different um
polyphenols they help to assimilate
those as well yes um and so you have to
decide i suppose as a family you know
how's my how's my son or daughter had a
lot of antibiotics when they were a
young baby you know if you if you have
um
if you've had a caesarean or if you've
not had the opportunity to breastfeed um
or if your child had sepsis or some
other serious infection where they had
multiple courses of antibiotics those
things will play a part
um in making sort of the decision around
you know how to optimize nutrition
and so including lots of plant-based
foods including fermented foods is going
to be particularly helpful for those
children yeah my kids love sauerkraut we
like to make our own sauce out when we
have the time and if not we'll just buy
sauerkraut also coconut yogurt is a
great option as well our sourdough which
already has exactly it has those
probiotics in which is great
and there's so many you know sourdough
you mentioned as well
yeah yeah that's awesome i i think
that's a really great point in regards
to the specific nutrients and how it all
plays a role a lot of times we can get
very obsessed as humans with the
reductionists looking looking at things
in a reductionist lens rather than
holistically and how everything plays a
role how we absorb nutrients even it's
true yeah and even looking foods um as a
whole instead of going oh i'm only
eating dolls for iodine like well it's
good for a lot of different reasons too
yeah yeah exactly exactly and i think
it's about it's about understanding you
know your whole life and where
you know where you might find that with
children you've mentioned good sleep is
important moving their bodies is
important i mean even things like
spending time in nature can impact their
skin microbiome things like that
so yeah it's not just down to individual
nutrients a lot of the time but it
hopefully will improve parents
confidence especially when they're you
know going fully plant-based to know
that they can get all the things that
they need from certain things yeah yeah
and then on top of that like simplifying
your life trying to and that's that's
what i love too about a lot of the
parenting books that i read i don't know
if you read much on like
um respectful parenting conscious
parenting and all that but
um shivali siberia is someone i
interviewed who is all about just like
simplifying your life and just not
creating such a stressful life with your
kids and that that's helpful not only
just for their mental health but their
physical health as well yeah definitely
i haven't i'd like to read more than
that but it does make a lot of sense
yeah for sure so i have a question going
back a little bit to b12 is there a
specific type of b12 you recommend for
parents
most of the studies we have are on
cyanocobalamin being perfectly adequate
i know there are some
who prefer methylcobalamin because it's
said to be more bioavailable but we have
plenty of evidence to say that cynical
balance is just as well available
i think
the requirements for b12
differ depending on how frequently you
have it
so
because the absorption changes so if you
have
one microgram of vitamin b12 from a
fortified food then you're going to
absorb about half of that whereas if you
have a 2000 microgram supplement once a
week you only absorb a small fraction of
it but it's enough
so the amount that you absorb differs
depending on how frequently you have
yeah people actually really want to know
about i get a lot of questions from
parents and i'm like let's talk to a
physician about that like specific
amounts so what would you recommend for
people based on their age differences if
they're taking cya copolymer or
methylcobalamin either one well to keep
things simple i'd say to parents just
get yourself a b12 supplement and read
the packet and whatever the packet says
to give your child you give your child
that that keeps it simple yeah um but
generally speaking if you're an adult
and you're having fortified foods like
fortified nut milks or cereals or
margarines or um brewers yeast like
marmite in the uk or vegemite in
australia these are all sources of b12
that you can have in your diet a
nutritional yeast as well
so if you have
those two or three times a day you only
need about three micrograms
if you have a supplement once a day and
don't think about it
then 10 micrograms is the dose so
remember i said if you if you're having
it two or three times you only need
smaller amounts whereas if you have it
once you need 10 micrograms now actually
10 micrograms is still a tiny amount but
you just still do need it right now
babies and young children it would be
much less than that but again if you're
having it daily that's different from if
you're having it once a week how young
do you recommend parents start children
on b12 if they're eating a plant-based
diet so if you are a mum of a baby and
you're breastfeeding the baby you need
to make sure you have the b12 in your
breast milk so i think a good sort of
solid 10 microgram supplement a day is
is good for yourself for yourself yes
let's say that clear yeah for yourself
and then then it can pass through into
the breast milk and then once your baby
is beginning to wean yeah you start them
on a b12 supplement um and many of the
childhood supplements are combined so
you don't have to be like figuring out
what drops to give it's literally a lot
of them you just have one set of drops
and it has b12 um it could have things
like you know iodine or selenium or
whatever else you want to have in the
drops and multivitamin drops
but yeah it can be sort of naught point
i think it's like 0.9 micrograms a day
um one microgram a day when they're a
bit older maybe a toddler one and a half
micrograms as they get a bit older sort
of the five plus range
that's the kind of sort of range of
looking at they're very very small
amounts but they are vital
perfect okay i think that's really
helpful for parents um my next specific
nutrient that i want to ask about is
omega-3 and dha ala can we talk a little
bit about that in your thoughts on that
definitely so
we we know from a lot of studies that
dha so okay let's break it down omega-3s
are really important fatty acids we
can't make them in our own bodies so we
have to consume them
and in plant sources they come in short
chain form or ala is called
and you can get those from
hemp seeds chia seeds flax seeds walnuts
these are all amazing sources of
short chain omega-3 fatty acids or ala
now
the long-chain omega-3 fatty acids are
called epa and dha
and you tend to get those from
algae or algae
or fish they tend to be the biggest
sources of the long chain omega-3s
now when we consume plant-based omega-3s
in ala form
we don't always convert it to the
long-chain form
with the epa you can convert about 20 of
it dha
on average it's really small about one
percent conversion rate based on what we
know
so
a lot of people say okay well if you
can't make that much of it then maybe
you should go for maybe you have to eat
fish
and i'd say that that's not the case we
don't have any data to suggest that
people on
long-term vegetarian or vegan diets have
any issues with brain health in fact the
opposite is true
like long-term healthy plant-based diets
have been shown to be fantastic for
reducing risk of dementia
and there's you know there's absolutely
no evidence to suggest there's any
problem having said that given that we
know that dha is great for babies brain
development and for human brain
development i personally like to advise
parents to consider an epa dha
supplement for kids just to be on the
safe side
because
we don't always know what we don't know
so i personally give my children
an epa and dha algae-based supplement or
algae-based supplement because that's
where fish get it from it always comes
back to plants at the end of the day it
does it's the same with b12 b12 is made
by microbes it's not made by animals and
you know the um the right sort of epa
dha
long-term omega-3s are made by sea
plants algae or algae so i like to give
them that purest form of ready available
long-chain omega-3s
but we don't have guidelines to say that
that's necessary right so it's kind of
up to the parent's idea based on what
they're hearing exactly and i'd say you
know if you have if you're very
conscious about making sure you have
like multiple sources of flax seeds chia
seeds hemp seeds walnuts in good amounts
in your child's diet uh then
you know yeah i'm sure that the
plant-based sources are fine yeah that
is what we do that's what you do yeah we
we've never given our kids like a dha
supplement we've always done a lot of
hemp seeds and flax seeds um we
sometimes i'll add even up to like a
quarter cup into my smoothies i i add up
plenty of flax seeds into my smoothies
and hemp seeds into our kids smoothies
every single day we put it on salads
i put it in dressings and we just
incorporate it in a lot of different
ways and then our granolas because i
make a really great homemade granola
that has hemp seeds in it and we do like
a whole half a cup in the batch and then
we also add use flax seeds ground flax
seeds into our muffins and things like
that so we our kids eat a lot of hemp
seeds on a daily basis hemp seeds and
flax seeds chia amazing yeah so
um we've done well with that but i like
the different again the options and the
different scooters ways of living yeah
because you know maybe your kid doesn't
like hemp seeds i don't know
exactly but if you're aware okay hemp
seeds flax seeds cheese seeds walnuts
making them a daily thing yeah is
fantastic and especially as you
mentioned milling those uh flax seeds
because you don't necessarily get the
same nutrients if they are going
straight through yogurt yeah and you
know you're not necessarily assimilating
that so yeah plenty of plant-based
omega-3s um i generally like to advise
the supplement because yeah i am airing
on the side of the yeah which is good
it's a great it's a great thing i love
having all different kinds of
perspectives to bring for different
people and i think sometimes people can
be like okay omega-3s i'll do one
teaspoon of hemp seeds into my smoothies
but really like with my kids when i'm
making a batch of smoothie for my kids
i'll do like a quarter cup sometimes
half a cup of hemp seeds like in a
smoothie for my three or four children
yeah yeah you need you need big amounts
you need lots of it yeah so don't be
afraid of them yeah
i think we covered oh i think one other
nutrient of focus we could talk about
was maybe calcium and bone health for
kids what are your thoughts on that yeah
so calcium is i would say generally aim
for slightly higher than the recommended
nutritional intake for things like
calcium and the same for things like
iron as we talked about before
just because we want to make sure
because the nutritional guidelines are
based on a standard american diet or
standard western style diet and do you
think that's a good thing do you think
it should be like that i don't know if
it should be but that's the way it is
because that's what most people eat yeah
but so with that in mind if you're
thinking more about a plant-based diet
then we you know we have got the
oxalates and the phytates which are
completely natural
but they can sometimes mean that you
slightly do absorb slightly less so i
would say on a plant-based diet those
those recommended nutritional intakes
could be slightly elevated so you're
going to be aiming to have a bit more
calcium or a little bit more iron than
you would otherwise think of
but yeah calcium is important for bone
health and it's available from a number
of different sources
green veggies are great not so much
spinach
spinach
is hard to actually absorb the calcium
in spinach but thinking of broccoli or
bok choy or lettuce or cabbage these are
great sources of bioavailable calcium
and in fact broccoli has more
bioavailable calcium than cow's milk for
example
you can get it from
things like dried apricots dried figs
nut butters almonds you know there's
actually a ton of different sources of
calcium that you could hopefully
incorporate into your child's diet which
will allow them to have plenty of
calcium and interestingly
we didn't touch on vitamin d yet but
vitamin d helps to improve calcium
absorption
and vitamin d is something else that i
would generally advise people to
supplement whatever their dietary
pattern because it's hard to get through
your food we tend to make it through our
skin with sunlight exposure and i would
love to live in hawaii i'd love to be in
maui stunning myself yes um but alas
most of us uh especially where i live
there's not so much sun and it's quite
hard to make enough vitamin d whatever
our dietary pattern so i personally say
take a vitamin d supplement that will
help you to absorb even more of the
calcium that you're eating in your diet
which will be a great thing this sounds
like then there's like three
maybe i missed one but three specific
supplements you recommend for kids just
as a general to cover your bases
well first the fortified plant milks if
you're wanting to do that as opposed to
making more things from scratch and then
the b12
and then there was the dha the
algae-based dha and then the vitamin d
yeah yeah and interestingly if you're
having consciously fortified plant milks
you don't necessarily need to supplement
vitamin d because it will be contained
depending on how much they drink right
be contained in that and you know even
for people who live in tropical
environments it's just our modernized
world a lot of people are living indoors
all day and we're not living outside
near as much as we used to yeah as a
species
and so it's really comes down to your
lifestyle
in addition to where you're living in
your climate it's true your lifestyle
and your climate and if you have a
darker skin tone it's going to take
longer to be in the sun to make enough
vitamin d right so if you have
pasty white skin
then you know in the uk in the middle of
summer you're going to be wanting about
10-15 minutes of direct sunlight to the
face and hands to make enough right
every day and on top of that most people
are slathering sunscreen on
every not saying that that's a bad thing
but um when you take that into account
as well it lowers your absorption of
vitamin d it certainly does
and then if you have darker skin many
people from other
ancestral climates they will come and
have real issues getting enough vitamin
d certainly in british weather
probably in many other parts of the us
or canada as well right because the
darker skin tone means they're not going
to absorb as much vitamin d so it may
take even longer to get enough so just
take a supplement yeah everyone do you
feel that way for people who aren't
eating plant-based as well about vitamin
d i do that's why i say everything
everyone yeah it doesn't matter and
we're talking specifically plant-based
here because that's what we're
interested in and that's what we want to
encourage parents to feel reassured that
they can do but this is true across the
board and it's like what i mentioned
earlier with certain other nutrients of
focus across the board whatever they eat
many people are in fact vitamin b12
deficient and interestingly with the
study i mentioned it was the vegan
children that had the most because their
parents supplemented right whereas you
know
many people if we're going on to adults
now you know if you're over the age of
50 or if you have diabetes and you're on
um diabetes medications if you're on um
antacid medications uh you're gonna not
be absorbing as much vitamin b12 as you
need and you probably will need a
supplement right whatever you're eating
and then on top of it the stress like
stress-filled lifestyle that we as a
society live in i i really think it's
important to go back to that study you
were talking about or not study you were
talking about um ancestrally it was at
ireland where they were iodine deficient
okay i don't know how to say that but
but it really i think a lot of times
um holistic families who have a really
holistic approach and wanting to do
things naturally which i am all about as
you can very much tell but sometimes it
can get to such a point where where
people can want to be resistant to any
kind of modernized way of
maybe doing food because you think well
there must be a way to do without any
kind of modernized
way of even like healthcare right and
dentistry which i do want to get into
teeth health but sometimes if you get
too far back where you just want to
think well the way that we used to be
must have been optimal and perfect and
we never needed supplements back then
it's just not the case like even people
before
processed foods industry and people were
eating whole foods
had nutrient deficiencies for this that
or the other reason so i think it's
really important to take all that into
consideration and not um maybe be so
rigid as we sometimes want to be like
the natural
yeah it makes sense and even you
mentioned dental health even things like
making sure that you you know your child
learns to clean their teeth properly
right yes yes that's really important oh
i'm so excited to talk about this i get
questions a lot about that wait did we
finish the supplement thing should we go
into it uh i think we did so b12 is an
absolute must vitamin d is a must for
everyone regardless of what they're
eating children under five general
guidelines are that they should
supplement vitamin a and vitamin k and
vitamin d which in the uk comes in a
simple supplement form in the us i'm
sure there's something equivalent again
whatever they are eating that's the
interesting point i want to make to you
so yeah it's not specific to plant-based
diets yes yeah that's interesting about
the vitamin a whatever they're eating
why are they recommending like what are
your thoughts on that because sometimes
people like to say a plant-based diet
beta-carotene it's not real vitamin a
even though yeah why don't you talk
about the studies in regards to beta
carotene and vitamin a it's just
basically the guidelines in the uk are
there based on uh population patterns
over a long time yeah and the studies
that they have on childhood nutrition
there are a few gaps for most people
right so they just want to make sure
that
yeah well part of that could be also
because there's so much um nutritional
deficiency based on the standard of
standard way of eating in britain in
america as well but if you're being
really conscious like i wouldn't say
it's essential right for a plant-based
family to worry right but it's just what
the guidelines say yeah and you're
earring on the side of kashmir yes
exactly so it's like any nutritional
guideline is based on most populations
like in the uk we have the eat well
guide and that's focused on five or more
portions of fruits and veggies making
sure that you base your meals on whole
grains and starchy carbohydrates making
sure that you include more plant sources
of protein like beans and lentils making
sure you have less processed meat less
salt less sugar you know less saturated
fat these are common sense guidelines
based on years of observations and
populations right so you know it is a
little bit jarring when i see people say
well you know that's wrong or that's
kind of biased maybe it's different in
the us maybe there's more of an
influence with
food companies having a say in how the
guidelines are made but in the uk that's
far less likely and in the canadian food
guidelines again that is not influenced
by industry at all right and they really
talk about how important it is is to
have a predominantly plant-based plate
you know they don't include dairy they
say lots of water
whole grains beans lentils peas
vegetables fruits these are the real
focus of their guidelines and there's no
industry bias there whatsoever i'm so
glad you brought up canada because i
remember seeing that come out and how
integral and important that is to note
because we do have food industry
influence in america but what i am
seeing from like um a different end of
the spectrum type of way of eating like
more westerny price ancestral they kind
of tend to think it's the opposite that
it's like vegan propaganda that's
influencing the
like what's being advised to eat to eat
more vegetables and plants and fruits
and beans and stuff which is just
astounding to me because the animal
agriculture industry is huge in america
and just showing that
and the influence that it has in their
lobbying power so when you consider what
happened in canada without the influence
and how it showed it was actually a
plant predominant diet and having less
animal foods more plants that's what the
outcome was so that says a lot and
that's true for many other countries
guidelines and it's that way for a
reason you know people make nutrition
and dietetics their career you know
people people look at these studies for
tens of years and like decades if you
look at all of the different people that
create these guidelines it's that way
for a reason it's it's yeah it's just
the logical it's fascinating i think um
going back to the vitamin d thing really
quick we don't supplement with vitamin d
but we also have we do a lot of sunshine
in the tropics and we also we use
sunscreen but like in a very methodical
way like we if we're going out in the
sun for a 45 minute period of time with
the kids or when we're gardening and
they don't have their shirts on they get
their vitamin d that way without
sunscreen on but if we're going to the
beach for two three hours we put
sunscreen on all of us and so
so it's like a balanced approach where
like we're making sure they're getting
their bare skin our bare skin in the sun
without sunscreen for a period of time
but not
in excess yeah you're right i mean
that's that's a great way of looking at
it you don't want you obviously don't
want your child to burn
that's the number one thing you want to
avoid yeah but having said that
judicious sun exposure is really
important yeah and this is where there
is a little bit of tension i think in
in the sort of world of medics because
most dermatologists would suggest that
you should stay out of the sun between
11 and 3 when it's at its highest and
you should always have
sort of really good sunscreen on
whereas when you look at sort of
populations of people i think there was
a study from sweden that showed that
actually
the higher your chronic sun exposure the
lower your all-cause mortality and risk
of cancers was and so you have to think
okay well why is that and i think it's
probably related to
levels of naturally made vitamin d maybe
that's my hypothesis
and
you make most when the sun is at its
strongest so it's really so interesting
i think sometimes we want to look at one
thing as oh if it causes this then it
must be all bad for all the reasons
right like oh you know the dermatologist
like what you're saying in regards to
people who don't wear sunscreen might
have like as adults like definitely
wrinkles yeah you definitely get
wrinkles a lot more you know just way
out of your vein than you maybe you want
to be making sure you put more
but what is the balance of having a
healthy amount of sun exposure for the
optimal amount of benefits while also
reducing your risk of other things yeah
i know it's tough but also you don't
make it through the window so you have
to be actually outside you have to be
outside yeah okay so let's get into
teeth health and kind of piggyback on
the topic of k2 because that is
something and also just about oral
hygiene because that is a big a big
topic i think with healthy children a
lot of kids had have cavities on any
diet when you look at how many children
have cavities it's something like 54 at
least in america wow um i looked at um
the nih i was looking at like tooth
decay and the amount of kids that have
like two or three dental caries or tooth
rot to decay it's a really high amount
for a lot of different reasons so let's
talk about oral hygiene let's talk about
okay um
by saying i'm not a doctor you're not a
dentist yes
but logically logic and two mothers and
you are a doctor so you're smart oh
thanks ellen
okay let's just talk about that so
logically i'd say it's important to make
sure that you're limiting the free
sugars in your child's diet if you want
to make sure that they have general good
dental health so you're not going to be
wanting to give them a load of um like
fizzy um sugar sweetened
because that's clearly going to have an
impact on their dental enamel that
actually includes kombucha too our
holistic dentist is like kombucha is
what i see in my holistic families they
do too much kombucha right because it
causes difficulties with the enamel
right so fizzy drinks sugar sweetened
drinks that's that's the main thing i
say if you're going to be focusing on
anything that would be great um ensuring
that calcium is adequate which we've
already covered and you know the the k2
question i think
we now understand that it is um helpful
to have k2 for healthy bones um just as
it's important to have calcium just as
it's important to exercise and move your
body just as it is important for all of
these things
if your child has a history of having a
lot of antibiotics or you know as we
mentioned before things that would
inhibit their gut health then maybe you
consider having
a k2 supplement if you want to it's not
required by any guidelines
but if you want to you can so calcium
yes fermented foods yes
sugar sweetened beverages no
when it comes to things like juices and
smoothies just be aware that they can
have a lot of sugar in so you maybe want
to rinse your child's mouth out if you
you know if they've been prone to
cavities to make sure that they're not
you know got those free sugars hanging
around for too long don't clean their
teeth within half an hour of having
those sugary foods though because then
that's when the enamel is weaker so just
even that sugary foods include smoothies
and even just a bowl of fresh fruit like
we do the same thing whether your kids i
think even aren't prone to dental cat
like dental caries you still it's still
a good habit to get into i think to
rinse your mouth with water after having
like fresh fruit and smoothies yeah and
then waiting like you said 30 minutes to
brush your teeth wait to brush your
teeth so don't don't eat drape straight
before you brush brush your teeth so
that you can protect your enamel and
make sure your kids are brushing their
teeth properly as well uh dentists tend
to advise fluoride based toothbrush
toothpaste you don't have to do that
fluoride has been helpful for dental
hygiene but maybe less helpful for other
things so you don't have to use a
fluoride based toothpaste but if you do
again i would suggest probably rinsing
it out after you've used it and only
using small amounts i think parents can
sometimes overestimate how much to use
but other parents with a more natural
lifestyle may decide actually i don't
want to clean my kids teeth or you know
maybe they'll use the um those tongue um
scrapers
i would suggest it's worth cleaning
their teeth properly and making sure
that they're doing that just to make
sure that you reduce their risk of
cavities whatever whatever toothpaste
you want to use
totally and i think i think this is a
really important note to bring up in
regards to like just brushing their
teeth really well because a lot of
parents can tend to get a little bit
passive about it because you're like oh
it's such a pain or the kids don't want
to do it they resist me on it especially
if you're coming from like an attachment
parenting respectful parenting approach
it can be easy to be like oh they're
they really don't want to do it i don't
want to like force them to brush their
teeth too much but
education is super important as they
especially as they get older and can
understand better um so like all of our
kids are in the habit of rinsing their
mouth with water after they have fresh
fruit and you know waiting 30 minutes to
brush their teeth and then the actual
brushing teeth part we use an electric
electric toothbrush yeah and that's
great yeah electric toothbrushes and i
know it's tempting to want to just use
the bamboo one and be all zero waste but
the electric toothbrush just cleans your
teeth so much better and going to the
dentist on a regular basis for clean for
checkups it's this is again one of the
things that i brought earlier how
sometimes i think natural parents can go
a little too far with the wanting to be
so natural where we just
ban all western anything right but
taking your kids to regular dental
checkups so that if they do have a small
cavity that you you can either get it
filled or
have ways to approach it instead of just
like ignoring it to where it festers and
causes more bacteria and more cavities
which is what so many people find
themselves in a place of because they
neglected a tiny little cavity that
could have just gotten filled and then
just taking better dental hygiene yeah
for sure if you have a cavity it has to
be filled yeah you want to be increasing
risk of infection yeah you only increase
like spreading it and having more and
more and then just like making sure to
brush the full two minutes and you know
you can do fun things like there's like
a toothbrush app with like these little
bouncy little cartoon characters that
brush their teeth with you so that they
get excited to brush their teeth and i i
found that really helpful too so that
the kids get the all of them and it kind
of shows them where to go so they learn
and reach all of their teeth um so i
think that that's really helpful too
yeah
i'm really passionate about the teeth
health and um i think starting at a
young age as well do you have thoughts
on like how young of an age you should
start like brushing their teeth really
well is it basically just as soon as
they start solid foods or what do you
think yeah i think to make it playful
from when they're starting to wean is
great so that it's just part of their
routine when they're having more food is
is when you start to clean their teeth i
don't think it's you don't need to clean
your baby's teeth but yeah they don't
have any yeah
basically when they start to grow teeth
and they start to wean then that's a
great time to to think about making it
playful and introducing that right my
kids had like kofax had like six teeth
before he was six months old and when he
started having solid foods probably
around like seven or eight months old he
was still breastfeeding we weren't
weaning but since he was having solid
foods that's kind of when we started
brushing yeah
yeah and also about the fluoride thing
my holistic dentist talks a little bit
about this other ingredient that's like
a great alternative to fluoride which is
like hydroxy i forget the exact word
have you heard of it i think that's
right yes i'll put it right here on
video overlay if you're watching this on
video um but she talks really highly of
that and there's a good idea our
toothpaste bite toothpaste that we use
has is that has that ingredient in it
yeah it's good okay oh and also flossing
yeah this is another thing that i think
parents can really put on the back
burner and just think oh just you know
maybe once a month but no like we floss
our kids teeth every day in the evenings
before bed and i know it's a pain but
just try your best to make it fun and
not make it like so i don't know not fun
we'll sing songs and you know now when
we teach our older kids sandy and elvis
like how to do it so now they basically
know how to do themselves but we still
check yeah and doing that every night
but i think i can't drive this home
point home enough because a lot of times
i see people kind of jump to a
conclusion like this must be what caused
my kids to have a couple cavities or
four cavities or tooth decay or tooth
rot but a lot of times there's so much
more to the story on how
what what kind of like diet someone was
eating how good their oral hygiene was
were you taking your kids to regular
dentist checkups so that you could like
dip something in the butt but i'm so bad
at that phrase but bud i always want to
say but it's to do with flowers oh okay
i want to say nip it in the butt i don't
know i'm in the bud but that way you can
like take care of it from the beginning
get advice from your dentist because
they do have good advice so that's their
job in regards to teeth health we really
like our holistic dentist that we go to
and our kids have great teeth fabulous
yeah yeah that's some good advice okay
great so let's get into breastfeeding
because i know a lot of people have
questions about breastfeeding because of
course obviously breastfeeding is like
the most nutritionally wonderful food
for babies
but people have concerns and questions
like what if i don't make enough breast
milk and what should i do if i can't
breastfeed um you should just go ahead
and start and i have thoughts too and
yeah i'll just piggyback off yeah you
piggyback yeah so i mean breastmilk as
everybody most people know is is great
because it's made specifically for your
baby and it has something called hmos
human milk oligosaccharides which are a
type of specialized protein which is
really helpful for helping to feed
and seed a really great microbiome from
a very young age so
and also we have these amazing receptors
in our nipples in our areola area that
pick up on what antibodies baby needs so
it helps to reduce risk of diarrhea and
infections and other issues so
yes of course breast milk is great but
not everybody can so i think first up
it's really important to support new
mothers in that journey i myself found
it really painful
and i knew as a doctor yeah breast is
best and that's what we tell everybody
but when you're doing it yourself it's a
whole other story you know it's so
painful especially if you have a child
has a difficult latch or their tongue
tie or
or you just start off with the wrong
technique and then you end up if the
baby's sucking on the nipple and not the
areola
you start to get quite sore
you can get cracks and chaps and
inflamed and infected areas mastitis you
know there's a few issues so if you know
about the issues in advance that's great
because then you know what to expect you
know how to
deal with these things early if they
happen and you know you ultimately want
to be supported on your breastfeeding
journey because if you are a vegan
parent it's really
the very best choice it's not it's not
just the best choice but it is the
optimal choice because you're not going
to necessarily want to use the um cow's
milk based formulas for your baby
so yeah if you can breastfeed that's
ideal
and hopefully you can get support along
the way i had support myself from a
government-funded clinic that helped
mums to you know do like a breastfeeding
advice which was great
i used nipple shields for a while i used
a pump an electric pump for a while to
sort of take the pressure off
i had to do it whilst going back to work
after a relatively short time just six
months i was then having to pump at work
so there's a lot of considerations
a lot of practicalities that you don't
really be aware of until you're doing it
yourself so yeah i think encouraging
mums to at least have an understanding
about what it could involve
and one of the things i hear a lot in my
practice is that mums worry that
if the baby starts to cluster feed or
feeding a lot more in the night or seems
more hungry that they're not producing
enough milk actually chances are they
are producing enough milk and it's a
completely normal process for the baby
to cluster feed when they want to try
and they're going through a growth spurt
and they want to just kind of stimulate
more milk production then you go ahead
and make more milk absolutely um so
that's so so don't start weaning because
you think they're hungry because chances
are
actually that's just their way of
getting more milk out of you i'm so yes
i'm so passionate about that because i
think so many times we're very quick to
not um believe in ourselves and know
that we can
um and do produce the right amount of
milk for our for our babies and so it's
easy to want to think oh no i don't have
enough milk when really if we could
understand the biological process of
what's happening is your baby is
signaling to your body to produce more
milk as it goes through a growth spurt
and that is a beautiful good thing so
you just have to keep going and it takes
a week or two weeks and then before you
know it they're settled back down and
it's not such a fussy feat because
you're bought you taught your
your baby taught through his or her
suckling to make more milk so it's a
good thing and you know like it or not
most of our milk production is in the
early hours of the morning
so keeping your baby near you you don't
want to be having to get up and turn the
light on and wake up you just want to
try and do it as easy and quick as
possible yeah so that you feel more
rested i think that's important i think
a lot of new moms worry i've got to get
the right position and i've got to turn
the lights up and figure out what i'm
doing and you know that can then also
cause you to have problems with your
sleep because it's hard sometimes to
sleep with the newborn you know it's
going to be a tough weeks and years you
want to make it as easy as possible on
yourself
so ideally perhaps keep them very close
by maybe even right next to your bed or
some parents like to co-sleep as well um
although i would say if that's something
that you're interested in doing make
sure that you don't drink alcohol yes or
medication or any medications that can
interfere with your ability to wake up
in the night and obviously not smoking
as well yes absolutely yeah
for sure oh that's so good i'm super
passionate about breastfeeding um and i
really one of my biggest goals while
being on social media like if i can look
back at my time on social media when i'm
an old woman and i think what were some
of my biggest most important priorities
in hopefully inspiring or just i don't
know helping is like trying to empower
women to
um be able to breastfeed because there's
so much confusion like i know the first
time that i breastfed i was so confused
i was scared i was crying a lot my
nipples hurt i also did the nipple
shield for a while i would call my
midwife just in tears because i like
just didn't understand how to do it i
couldn't get him to latch it's just so
confusing and we tend to think that it
just must be like a very instinctive
process where we must we must just
naturally know how to do it the moment
that we become a mother but really your
baby is learning how to breastfeed just
like you are learning how to breastfeed
and we really need the guidance and
support and love from like a um
like a well-seasoned
breastfeeder who knows how to breastfeed
either a lactation consultant or a
mother of some sort who
knows how to breastfeed and can guide
you throughout that because it's really
not just like a 30 minute call or one
little consultation it takes a lot of
practice and
so i'm really passionate about like
anyone if you do rest if you've known
how to breastfeed to support any young
new mother that you know that is
struggling and go to their home if they
want your help you know obviously don't
barge in but if they want your help
you know i'm like i'm here if you need
any help like i just i just love that i
think once i figured it out and once we
really had a good breastfeeding
relationship it was so easy and it was
the most beautiful thing ever it was
just really really hard in the beginning
yeah and then after all the other ones i
knew what i was doing so it was a breeze
it was just so easy because i knew
exactly what i was doing and there's so
many different questions and concerns
and
so i have a breastfeeding ebook online
that i made really affordable it's only
ten dollars and anyone who is listening
to this if they can't afford it just
email me even if they can't afford even
the ten dollars just email me and i will
send it to you because it's just
something i'm really passionate about
and i worked with a lactation consultant
who's here on island named natalie
marcus and she helped me write it and
yeah there's just so many so many things
that i think can be really helpful that
i wish i knew when i had first had my
first exactly and it's interesting
because my journey as a doctor and my
journey as a mother have been very
interesting because what you learn as a
doctor is actually not the same as what
you learn as a mother and for me my
understanding of the breastfeeding
journey has been infused with a lot more
compassion
because i found it so
hard
yeah and i want every
like to be mum out there to know that
sometimes it's hard and that's okay and
as long as you get the support you can
hopefully make it through but even if
you don't and your mental health is
suffering please you know just remember
that a fed baby is is
the same please yeah don't don't feel
that way because you know many many moms
get so
upset when they feel like they've failed
and so having the right support in place
early is important because it's not
always natural and it is hard and it can
be painful but then hopefully if you're
getting through that and you're feeling
good then it's very empowering however
if you haven't and there's other reasons
why you haven't been able to breastfeed
that's okay yeah there's actually some
really extreme circumstances and
situations as well like if you needed
surgery you'd have to be on medication
and can't breastfeed or i i one of the
women that i donated breast milk to had
like really really bad mystitis in one
breast and had to have surgery i forget
what the exact reason was but on one of
her breasts so she could only nurse from
one breast for like three months
straight so having that donated milk
from me like helped supplement that for
her so i love what you're saying about
no shame and like supporting all women
through whatever their journeys are
because everyone's just doing their best
yeah and at the end of the day i think
like my passion stems from just help
hopefully helping to
like encourage that in a way that
empowers women to be able to do it and
for those who can't and aren't able to
um i'm really passionate about donating
breast milk that's another part of this
puzzle piece of like if i look back in
my life
and what i would be hoping to have
inspired other mothers to do is that if
you can breastfeed if you are a
comfortable situation and you make
plenty and lots of milk consider
donating your breast milk to women who
need it i've always always been able to
find someone who needed
breast milk it was never a problem so
with every kid after the first one the
first one i didn't do this but with the
second third and fourth kid
about four weeks postpartum i start to
pump every morning
first thing in the morning because it's
the best i mean i have all this in my
breastfeeding ebook tips ebook on like
the best times to pump but
to be able to maximize the amount of
milk that you get out but basically you
teach your body to make more milk just
like with the cluster of eating through
pumping you can also do that and so i
teach my body at an early postpartum
phase to make more milk so that i can
pump eight ounces every single morning
put it in the freezer and donate it with
every kid i've been able to donate over
2 000 ounces of breast milk and it's
amazing so rewarding and if more of us
could do that how supported we could
help other mothers who aren't able to
breastfeed so true yeah i remember
pumping with my two uh i ended up i
ended up breastfeeding for i think a
year and a half with both um
but i stored my own breast milk because
i didn't i wasn't really aware of a
brass donation scheme where i am um so
it would be great to know more and
hopefully be able to encourage women to
do that but i uh also um stored my own
breast milk in the freezer and i
stockpiled it because it can last in the
back of your freezer for a year yeah so
for me that was so important because i
had to go back to work after six months
and i was able to continue giving my
children my breast milk when i wasn't
there because i can't then just you know
it was there it was in the freezer it
was it was available and yeah that was
really helpful for me i also did that
with my first kid i was a waitress at
the time so we have a much shorter um
postpartum ability with government
assistance and so i went back to work at
three months postpartum and also
also
i know it's really a shame we should
really be looking at these other
countries that have longer postpartum
phase and even have fraternal um
postpartum some states do that now
actually though where they have
fraternal pay for postpartum not
postpartum but sorry like uh what's the
word like after you have a baby yes like
maternity maternity but fraternity leave
yes that um anyway so i did the same as
well and i would pump in the back of
because it was such a priority to me so
like there would they by law at least in
california at the time you were half you
had the every workplace was supposed to
have like a breastfeeding room but at a
restaurant they did not have this so i
ended up having to pump like in the
manager's office and like they would
like close all the cameras and grab all
the keys from the different chefs and
everything and it was totally
embarrassing but it was worth it
it should be easier for women it really
needs to be easier yeah i was doing it
at work in my office
they're pumping between my patients
right yeah it's it's hard it is it's a
lot of work it is it is a lot of work
yeah but it's worth it i've got a funny
story my sister was helping me uh in the
early days i was crying i was in pain i
had you know chapped nipples and i asked
her to go down to the pharmacy for me
to get me a nipple shield
yeah so she went down there she's a lot
younger than me and she's never you know
she she didn't she wasn't familiar with
these things and she just remembered it
wrong so she went up to the pharmacist
and said
um i'd like to buy some nipple clamps
please
the father says look to her i think
you're in the wrong shot i think you
need to go to the erotic church yeah
that's not here and she was like oh um
ah i don't mean that what were they
called
that is hilarious
so funny i also use a nipple shield
because i could with the first baby
because i couldn't get the latch proper
properly and then i once i got my baby
on the nipple shielded for consistent
amount of time i really wanted to wean
him off of the nipple shield i was so
annoyed of it having to like put it on
and wash it all the time so i actually
went to like a baby
new mother support group who like i got
amazing advice from these different
women how to wean him off of it and
within like i think three weeks i got
him off of it after he was like it was
like three months old and then three
weeks after that once i learned some
tips so that was really helpful as well
to go through like breastfeeding support
groups it is but for people who don't
have that kind of support who don't have
the option to get dominated breast milk
which for i just want to say if you're
interested in that human milk for human
babies in america at least they have
facebook groups all around the country
in different big cities to where you can
go and ask for a donated breast milk and
say you're looking for it and different
mothers can connect with you so check
that out humanmilkforhumanbabies.com
and their facebook groups but for those
who don't have that option what is your
best advice for formula so it depends on
the age of your baby um i think for
most
most parents who are raising their
children vegan they're going to want to
breastfeed until the age of one ideally
and then they could go straight to a
fortified plant milk rather than a dairy
milk that's the easiest option
if that's not possible
then the type of milk would actually
really depend on what age the baby is
because if your baby is newborn
then guidelines for the vegan nutrition
guideline is to avoid
soy milk based formulas based on their
body size and the amount of soil that
you have in the formula
now interestingly i spoke to a
pediatrician about this and she has been
she's called dr miriam
martinez biage and she works at imperial
i believe in london
and she was telling me that she's worked
with countless families who either
because of cow milk protein allergy or
because they want to raise their
children vegan did not want to go for
a cow's milk based formula she said that
they tend babies tend to tolerate soy
based formulas really well they tend to
like the taste of them and they have
been safe and effective used for over
100 years and in fact a recent
meta-analysis has compared
the soy milk formula fed babies with
cow's milk formula fed babies and uh
they basically concluded that there was
no significant difference between the
two in terms of their development which
i think is really important to highlight
that being said she does give a few
caveats so if your baby is premature and
spent time on nikku it's best to avoid
soy milk based formulas
um if they were born with congenital
hypothyroidism it's best to avoid soy
based soy milk based formulas
and it's generally much less of a
concern really once they're six months
plus and you're beginning the weaning
process
it's very common and normal to be giving
your child a soy milk based formula at
that stage when they're six months plus
as well as the weaning so you can do
them together and yeah it seems to be a
perfectly valid option
so yeah there's also hydrolyzed rice
based formulas which are made in parts
of europe they may be made in the u.s as
well they are also deemed to be safe and
appropriate for babies they don't
contain arsenic because there is a
concern with rice milks in general for
older children it's best to generally
avoid those under the age of five
because of a risk potential risk of
arsenic exposure that's not the case
when it comes to hydrolyzed rice based
formulas for babies there's no risk
there
so yeah it's it's an interesting one i
think most people would just go for
cow's milk based formulas but what i
would say is whatever you choose to do
most important thing under the age of
one is to never make your own milk for
your baby okay let's talk about that so
that's kind of a trend i'm seeing a
little bit on like how to make your own
even raw milk formula or just like
making your own formula can you explain
why you think that's so important to not
make that well the food standards agency
tells us not to do it because there are
potential infection risks um which you
know is very important to realize and
also big nutritional gaps
so the main two reasons are nutritional
gaps for the baby and infection risks
for the baby
please please use formula
or breast milk under the age of one yep
and actually a lot of these like vegan
parent horrible stories that you were
talking about earlier was from babies
who were under a year old that were or
even under six months old that were just
literally not fed breast milk or formula
yeah exactly come on how are you calling
that a vegan apparently that's just like
a
not well informed parent yeah it's true
yeah so i would say
100
formula or breast milk under the age of
one over the age of one
you can give them any milk you want um
except the rice milk as i mentioned um
but i would generally advise people to
go for
for fortified soy milk because
if you are somebody that doesn't plan as
much as someone like yourself might then
it just gives you those extra
reassurances that you're giving them the
extra bits and pieces like the calcium
vitamin d iodine but also
um soy milk is nutritionally very
similar to cow's milk in terms of the
protein content and soy beans are you
know a complete source of proteins
complete source of all essential amino
acids as well interesting so yeah yeah
so all that is really interesting i've
never actually spoken on any of that
because i am like i said my main goal is
to like hopefully inspire more women to
breastfeed or hopefully more inspiring
women to be able to breastfeed and also
to other women who have plenty of milk
to donate so that we can help other
women to at least even supplement with
some donated breast milk if they're
doing formulas they at least get some of
it um that would be fantastic we need a
lot more of it though and it's obviously
not it's idealistic and so that's just
not in the place that we're at um but
anything to help more women to be able
to breastfeed would be amazing while at
the same time being like not shameful
and loving and supportive of everyone in
their own stories um my own personal
like story with breastfeeding i
breastfeed all my kids to around two
that's what the world health
organization says is optimal yeah yeah
so the world health organization says
that breastfeeding tattoo is optimal and
that you could decide to do it for
longer if you wanted to yeah it's not a
problem yeah actually one of my kids i
did breastfeed for even longer than that
and did like tandem nursing for a while
but i'm like oh that was a lot tandem
nursing that was a lot
but two years old is um
is kind of how all of my kids have been
and then we don't do any fortified milks
like i said earlier so do you feel like
for people who are planning their well
planning their diet eating a wide
variety and also breastfeeding like it's
extended to like what the world health
organization recommends do you feel like
a plant milk is necessary i feel like
you've already said not if you're well
planning but just to like kind of bring
that home with the different ways of
raising kids plant-based no i mean it's
very personal to each family so it's not
necessary yeah no it's just another good
option and interestingly
i should also say that breastfeeding is
helpful for mum it reduces risk of
breast cancer and
it's a form of contraception
because you're not going to be ovulating
especially i would say as a caveat in
the first six months of breastfeeding
yeah after the child starts weaning yeah
you're careful you need to be much more
careful
but during that first six months if you
are exclusively breastfeeding and the
child has no other supplemental milk
your baby um just as having your milk
then there's a 98 percent effectiveness
in terms of contraceptive you know from
breastfeeding perfect as well
people don't always really there's a lot
of benefits yeah people don't always
know yeah so i have a question that's
kind of like well kind of bringing
things back to the other topic of
supplements and nutrients do you think
kids or parents should be getting their
children's blood levels checked
regularly or sometimes or never not
necessary what are your thoughts on that
i don't think it's generally necessary
it's not something that we have
guidelines on in the uk it's not
something that that's generally
advocated for
if you are able to
feel confident in providing your child
with a variety of nutrient-rich foods
and your supplementing regularly on a
plant-based diet with vitamin b12 and on
any diet with with vitamin d and
following guidelines perhaps very
similar in the us to the uk
just a multivet with vitamins a and k as
well giving them a nice broad rich diet
full of diverse plant foods
you don't need to get their blood levels
too yeah as i mentioned the german study
the vichy study that the vegan children
had
an abundance of a variety of different
nutrients that the omnivorous children
had less of i didn't i'm not saying they
didn't have them but yeah there's so
much emphasis on making sure that it's
safe actually it's it's it's abundant um
and as i said there's just a few key
nutrients to be more aware of which i
think we've covered
really well yes oh we've covered it so
good i only have like one more question
because i feel like we've talked about
so much amazing things but what do you
think after breastfeeding those first
foods should be on a healthy diet
so yeah um you wanna it depends if you
wanna what age you're weaning so
generally it's from six months some
parents choose to wean a bit earlier
than that if their children if they deem
their baby to be ready so if the baby is
sitting upright independently able to to
control their head able to
grasp at foods able to want to put them
in their mouth
have the coordination to grab and put
things in their mouth
then they can be a bit younger than six
months right
um but if they are six months uh four or
five six months then you generally would
be going for more pure aid options
rather than baby-led weaning of grabbing
actual solid foods like you know steamed
carrot sticks or broccoli and stuff like
that they're a little bit young
so
sort of four to six seven months you'd
be thinking okay well let me steam some
vegetables um so things like sweet
potatoes and carrots and
normal potatoes and mashed up things
like mashed up beans with breast milk or
formula if that's what you're using
[Music]
so that they've got these new tastes
that they can start to experiment with
but
their milk should still be their main
source of nutrition so you're not really
aiming at that young age to give them
their nutrition through food it's more
experimentation
and then as they get sort of seven eight
nine months you're going to be more
confident in giving them actual sort of
more solid type foods giving them the
opportunity to
feel what different textures and feel in
the mouth as well which will help their
their jaw and help their gums and help
their teeth coming through so that's
another nice thing to introduce like nut
butters as well um like things like
little rice cakes and
veggie veggie sticks you know stuff like
that is really nice to be able to offer
the off your child chopped up like you
know dates or whatever else you want to
give them that's small i would be just
cautious to say things like tomatoes and
grapes you should always cut in half you
don't want to risk your child choking
gagging is actually quite normal when
you're learning how to eat so
please don't be alarmed if you see your
child kind of pushing a food forward
with their tongue on occasion or their
eyes watering and they're kind of going
yeah um
that gagging try not to freak out
because that's actually a normal part of
them figuring out
the
way of moving their jaw to chew
and
swallow which are all skills that the
baby has to learn yeah
if they're if they're choking that's
different so maybe a basic first aid
course if you you know if you're not
sure what to do and give them the back
snaps or hold them upside down but
gagging you don't need to worry too much
that's actually quite common and normal
um so yeah that's kind of what you'd
start with and then
i think probably from about the age of
nine months onwards you basically be
giving them chopped up versions of what
you would normally eat as a family yeah
you don't really having having to make
separate meals for your baby and
actually that can kind of encourage more
picky eating habits if you if you start
at such a young age to be like oh i
don't want them eating what i'm having
because mine might have too much garlic
in it or too much of this but if you
just start like feeding them while
you're feeding your kids you know that
develops really healthy habits with your
kids in your home yeah exactly just just
be aware
salt yes some some parents really have a
yeah a desire to have more salty food
yeah you don't want to have too much
salt in the in the chili children's
meals maybe add salt later if you want
to have salt
or being the example is such a huge
thing like if you know maybe we
shouldn't be having like too much salt
like just as a family adopt that so that
your kids are all just eating in the
same way yeah and hopefully they'll
start to reap those benefits and yeah
i mentioned earlier briefly in the
podcast about how allergies are
increasing
asthma eczema and food intolerances
having a healthy plant-based diet is a
great way of reducing that risk so yeah
it's yeah it's all good that's great i
also want to say that like for us our
children's first foods are always
avocado or banana papayas because that's
like what's local to us coconut
fresh coconut flesh that's soft not like
the super hard coconut um and then just
and we generally actually wait until
they're like seven or eight months just
for the ease and also until they have
like a lot of teeth where it's just easy
because we do more baby lead weaning
yeah and then as they get older none of
it and it is mostly breast milk even
through the whole year of life so even
at one year our babies don't really
start eating a significant portion of
their calories from like foods until
like 12 or 14 months it just has
happened very naturally like that for us
just because they are more interested in
breast milk and then food is more play
in the first year of life yeah and just
introducing new foods so what about for
people and since we're talking about
introducing foods who who wonder should
i give my child
my plant-based child animal food so that
to see if they're allergic or i get
questions like that sometimes what are
your thoughts on that so it depends if
you have a strong family history of
allergy yourself for say for example you
have a strong
nut allergy
then the national institute for allergy
and infectious diseases states that it's
actually really important to see whether
your child may or may not have an
allergic reaction to that and the same
could be said as well for things like
eggs
so
the choice is obviously up to the
individual family
but if you have a strong allergic
reaction to eggs then the guidance is
that you should give egg to your child
early on to see what happens so the main
two reasons being you want to make sure
that you know if they're at risk of
dying if they are exposed to egg
inadvertently when they're older right
but also maybe they might choose to eat
egg when they're not in your presence
sometime and you don't know you want to
know how serious you want to know if
that's something that's actually going
to cause a problem for them
so there was a really interesting study
based out of the uk
it's called lipas
and it was a trial of high-risk babies
and it was with regard to not allergies
actually
and what they did is they looked at what
the parents chose to do with exposing
their baby to nuts
so it's perfectly
normal and natural to give your baby a
nut butter in the first year of life
and when the parents gave their
high-risk babies a nut butter between
the ages of um four and ten months
out of those sample high-risk babies 1.9
percent of them developed a nut allergy
with the families where they decided to
avoid nuts completely and then they
exposed the child to a nut
after the age of three
then 14
of those babies or children developed a
nut allergy interesting so it seems like
actually
previous advice is wrong the earlier the
exposure the less likely they would be
to develop an allergy right
so
i don't think it's particularly
important or relevant if you don't have
a family history of allergies so if you
want to raise your child vegan and you
don't have a family history of allergies
there's no reason to give your child
eggs for example yeah but if you do
then there may be some benefits to it
right like especially if it's like
strong allergies for things like
anaphylactic type of allergy exactly you
want to be prepared yeah yeah um and do
you think though maybe the allergy thing
could be associated with different
factors and
that are modern to today's world
uh maybe and and there's different kinds
of allergy so you know we know i know we
talked earlier about adaptations for
dairy for example
still around 70 of the global population
is lactose intolerant that's not
strictly an allergy but it's an
intolerance
and so
i think
when there's such a strong societal
focus on giving your child cow's milk
you're actually potentially doing them a
disservice especially if you're in the
global majority yeah that has a lactose
intolerance yeah which then again just
goes back to our physiology and what
we're really supposed to be eating
exactly
okay so yeah wow we talked about so much
this is amazing thank you for everything
that you shared i feel like we covered a
lot we did like a lot we did and we
didn't even deep dive into so many other
things yeah but that was good i loved
that i love it yeah we could totally do
a deep dive part two another time
maybe you'll come back to hawaii i'd
love to come back maybe i'll go to
britain one day yeah sure
great well thank you so much i am so
appreciative of all that you shared this
was just amazing and i think so helpful
so great thank you ellen it's been an
absolute pleasure great okay bye
[Music]
you